Oh, mein Mikrofon funktioniert.
Der Wackelkontakt in meinem Verlängerungskabel ist nämlich schlechter geworden.
Und jetzt hat es zwischenzeitlich schon Aussetzer.
Wenn ich einfach nur ein bisschen was oben auf dem Schreibtisch rumrücke.
Deswegen wundert es mich, dass es jetzt funktioniert.
Ich muss das Kabel unbedingt mal austauschen.
Aber das ist nicht einfach nur ein Kabel.
Das ist halt Mute-Button und Kabel in einem.
Es ist sehr praktisch, ein extra Mute-Button zu haben.
Das ist uralt.
Das ist richtig.
Richtig alt.
Was ich da habe zum Verlängern.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch mal kurz.
Das ist noch von dem allerersten Headset, was ich jemals hatte.
Also das ist bestimmt 20 Jahre alt.
Das war ein Microsoft Sidewinder Headset.
Genau dieses Billigding, Alter.
Hatte ich damals, ich glaube, das habe ich geschenkt bekommen.
Das war das erste, genau das Ding, Alter.
Das war das erste Headset, was ich je hatte.
Übelster Crap, Leute.
Richtig massive Crap.
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Das war auf Ear.
Wie nennt man das? On Ear?
Also, das hat auf dem Ohr drauf gesessen.
Das Mikrofon war absoluter Müll.
Aber, was ich bis heute verwende, ist dieses Verlängerungsding hier.
Dieses Verlängerungskabel verwende ich bis heute noch.
Es hat ein Mute-Button.
Und du kannst mit den Knöpfen,
theoretisch, noch verschiedene Audio-Channels und sowas durchschalten.
Wobei, das verwende ich nicht.
Ich benutze es eigentlich nur als Verlängerung und Mute-Button.
Man hat ein Mute-Button für Sound und Mute-Button für Mikrofon.
Beziehungsweise, ne, man hat ein Mute-Button für Sound und für Mikrofon.
Und das ist halt so kaputt schon.
Das ist erschienen 2003 oder so.
2005, okay.
Ja, also sprich, es ist 18 Jahre alt.
Also 18 Jahre alt ist das Verlängerungskabel, was ich verwende für mein Biodynamics gerade.
Halt wegen dem Mute-Button.
Und das ist so kaputt mittlerweile.
Das ist so wackelkontaktig alles.
Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, ob das gescheit funktioniert mit dem Stream.
Battlefield 2042 macht ja immer mal Probleme.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall umschalten.
Von Display Capture auf Game Capture gleich.
Sonst klappt das Ganze nicht.
Habe ich überhaupt noch Platz auf der Platte hier?
Oh, ich hoffe, ich habe es noch installiert.
Habe ich es noch installiert?
Ja, okay.
Noch mal Glück gehabt.
Wo ist der Ton?
Ist da.
Geht alles.
Aber mein Mikrofon ist falsch eingestellt.
Es ist zu laut.
Moin Patrick, danke schön für den Sub.
Twitch Mason, danke schön für den massive Sub.
Maus-Input sollte besser sein.
Egal.
PPGA-AIM ist wieder am Start.
Leute, ich bin mittlerweile 38.
Und übe 0, was Shooter angeht.
Schon seit einer Weile, weil es nichts gibt, was ich gerne spiele.
Also PPGA-AIM ist hier am Start.
Wobei es tatsächlich ganz gut läuft.
Aber mein Battlefield verlernt man nicht.
Was?
Schließe jede Stufe ab?
Was zum?
Das sieht jetzt anders aus.
Ach, guck mal.
Das ist jetzt der Boost Train.
Das ist jetzt nicht der Sub, sondern der Boost Train.
TS Fuchs, danke schön für den Sub.
So.
Okay, das muss jetzt erstmal Shader kompilieren.
Und drei Stunden irgendwelche Dinger machen.
Postchamp?
Tatsächlich.
Funktioniert einfach.
Nice.
Ich meine, die Musik mag vielleicht ganz gut dazu passen.
Aber die machen wir gleich aus.
So, erstes Mal umschalten.
Game Capture.
Auf Battlefield.
Weil ansonsten buggt das nämlich rum.
Kann ich gleich umschalten.
Jop, dankeschön für den Sub.
Guck mal, sogar die Animation ruckelt schon.
Das Game macht im Hauptmenü
ultra viel
CPU Last.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Keckel.
Fuck, das ist das Hauptmenü.
Wollen die New World Konkurrenz machen?
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Mit Grafikkarten, die verrecken.
Ja, guck hier.
Skip Frames. Encoding lag.
Lul.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, wenn ich hier umschalte auf
Ingame Capture ist alles gut.
Also den Sinn habe ich noch nicht so genau
verstanden, ehrlich gesagt, warum das eine
besser ist als das andere. Aber okay.
Shitcoin, Mann.
Wirkt echt so.
Wisst ihr was wir mal schnell gucken müssen?
Gibt es vielleicht eine Option?
Gibt es eine Option um im Hauptmenü...
Okay, ist jetzt rhetorische Frage.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber gibt es eine Option
um im Hauptmenü
die FPS zu limitieren?
Mein Foff scheint mir hier
ein bisschen niedrig.
Muss ich gleich mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Kann man
FPS limitieren?
Vertical Sync?
Naja, nee, das wollen wir ja nicht.
Nee, ich glaube das geht nicht.
Also sprich, wenn man heizen will
einfach
mal Battlefield anschmeißen.
Vielleicht...
Komm, wir fragen mal Reddit dazu.
Reddit weiß doch bei sowas immer Bescheid.
Menü
CPU Usage
Battlefield statt
Erdgas, ja?
Naja, es ist ja eigentlich Strom statt Erdgas, aber
man könnte es auch... Battlefield
das wäre dann quasi
BAEG
BAEG, Battlefield anstatt Erdgas.
Das braucht alles Abkürzungen.
Fix low-high CPU Usage.
Naja, mir geht es nur im Hauptmenü.
Das Hauptmenü über Main...
100% CPU Usage,
da kann man nichts dran ändern wahrscheinlich.
You can fix it. DICE is aware of it.
Ach ja!
Ich würde sagen, DICE
lacked critical information.
Weil bis jetzt hat
DICE das ganze noch nicht gefixt.
Wie vieles andere
in dem Spiel auch, aber...
Die scheinen critical information nicht wirklich
zu lacken bei DICE, sondern...
Sie haben keinen Bock, die critical information
zu verarbeiten.
Brutal expectations, so sieht es aus.
Ja, also hier
einen Sleep einzubauen im Hauptmenü,
das stelle ich mir auch schon extrem
krass vor, das zu fixen.
Ist bestimmt
komplett...
Die Technik ist einfach...
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da, Leute.
Und jetzt ist auch...
Jetzt seht ihr, warum ich 32 GB RAM habe.
Weil ich Battlefield starten kann,
VMs offen haben kann,
120 Browser-Tabs offen haben kann,
alles kein Problem.
Habt ihr übrigens mitbekommen, dass
der Typ mit dem russischen Gas
gebannt wurde auf Twitch?
Es gab einen Streamer, der hat
den ganzen Tag sein
Gasherd angehabt
und hat halt
durchgefeuert.
Und es wurde gebannt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er einen neuen Account hat.
Null.
Ach ja, übrigens.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind,
wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat?
Wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat?
Also das habe ich mir genau so gedacht,
als ich das gelesen habe.
Ich habe von Anfang an nie diese
Faszination, die da manche aufbringen konnten,
für Gamestreaming
verstanden, okay?
Aber ich dachte mir so, ja, in gewisser Weise
theoretisch hat das Potenzial,
praktisch
wird das nix.
Und man sieht mal wieder, es wird
nix. Deswegen kann ich auch nicht verstehen,
was die Logitech
CEOs und
Top-Manager geritten hat, jetzt
einen Streaming-Handheld rauszubringen.
Streaming
daheim auf dem Desktop klappt doch schon nicht
gescheit. Beziehungsweise, was heißt klappt nicht?
Im Prinzip klappt das schon.
Will aber keiner haben.
Und dass das Mobile dann
über Mobilfunk noch ordentlich
funktionieren soll. Ich meine, ich habe ja schon Probleme,
Twitter zu refreshen, wenn ich heimfahre.
Und ich fahre heim von Frankfurt nach
Hanau. Also muss man sich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen. Das dürfte so eines der
meistgefahrenen Strecken in Deutschland
sein. Also ich fahre ja hier
Frankfurt, äh, sagen wir mal
Hauptbahnhof.
Ähm, naja.
So, und ich fahre ja im Prinzip
hier lang. So. Das ist quasi
eines der meistgefahrenen,
ne, nicht die S-Bahn. Das dürfte
eines der meistgefahrenen Strecken,
warum will der mir die S-Bahn auflabern, Alter?
Eines der meistgefahrenen Strecken überhaupt
sein in Deutschland. Ja, Frankfurt,
Hanau oder Frankfurt, Köln und sonst was.
Und selbst da habe ich Mobile-Aussetzer.
Wieso? Wie stellen die sich das
überhaupt vor?
So, jetzt machen wir mal Battlefield an,
weil ich merke schon, es laggt wieder
as fuck. Ich wohne im Ghetto.
Meinst du das Frankfurter Ghetto oder das Hanauer
Ghetto? Also ich wohne nicht
in der Nidderstraße in Frankfurt. Übrigens,
Fun Fact aus Frankfurt,
wo wir gerade dabei sind.
ähm,
Nidderstraße und
Münchnerstraße und die Ecke,
Kaiserstraße, da wo die ganzen
Drogenabhängigen und Kriminellen rumhängen,
da war es jetzt so schlimm, dass
die, ähm, sich
quasi die Ladenbesitzer dort
haben sich im Stich gelassen gefühlt von der Polizei
und haben daraufhin einen
privaten Sicherheitsdienst angeheuert,
der dort dann quasi die ganzen
Drogenabhängigen vertreibt
und Kriminellen vertreibt und als die Polizei
das mitbekommen hat, haben sie gesagt,
das sehen sie aber nicht gerne.
Dann haben die Ladenbesitzer gesagt, ja dann kommt doch öfters vorbei.
Und
jetzt kommt die Polizei öfters vorbei.
Und jetzt scheint
alles wieder gut zu sein.
Ich meine, ich frage mich, warum sie erst wieder so
ausatmen muss, ja?
Übrigens, eine Story
muss ich euch noch erzählen, wo wir gerade
bei Frankfurt sind, wo wir gerade bei Frankfurt sind.
Bevor wir bei Battlefield...
Wobei, komm, scheiß. Wir bauen uns mal
nebenbei eine Klasse.
By the way, das Game hat gerade wirklich keinen Sound.
Wir müssen gleich mal checken, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Äh, so.
Wir bauen mal ganz kurz was zusammen.
Was wollte ich euch denn jetzt gerade noch erzählen?
Genau.
Also, eine witzige...
Was heißt witzige Story?
Eigentlich ist es eher
bedenklich, ja, in Frankfurt.
Ich muss das Ding übrigens mal ordentlich benennen.
Äh, Moment. Wie ging unbenennen nochmal?
Aha.
Obviously, rechtsklick,
rename linksklick.
Äh, rename.
Hallo, ich möchte es markieren.
Nicht, nicht erlaubt.
Nicht im Scope.
A40 oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Hab gedacht, dass ich weiß, was es ist.
AM40 heißt das Ding.
So, also, nochmal Fun Fact, so aus dem
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Äh, ja. Also, als wir da mal
Mittagessen gewesen sind. Also, dass ihr euch mal so
grob vorstellen könnt,
was da so abgeht.
Also, Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel ist
ähm, quasi
das hier.
Also, wenn du hier aus dem Hauptbahnhof rauskommst.
Ah.
Haupt...so.
Aus dem Hauptbahnhof rauskommst.
Hier daneben hat Taunusstraße, Niddastraße,
sonst wie das hier ist Bahnhofsviertel.
Das ist da, wo die ganzen kriminellen, drogenabhängigen
Assis sind. Das geht im Endeffekt dann so
hoch hier bis zum Willy-Brandt-Platz
und dann hier im Main und zurück.
Also, das hier ist so quasi
das Bahnhofsviertel. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es
vielleicht sogar bis zur Zeil noch mit zählt.
Aber so richtig, die Assis, die sind eigentlich hier
am Hauptbahnhof. So. Und wir waren was
futtern. Das müsste...
Das müsste hier...
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Das müsste
hier irgendwie
so in der Ecke gewesen sein, ja?
Und...
Auf einmal...
Das habe ich euch glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
Recycle-Story, ich weiß.
Ja. Auf einmal
gegenüber auf der Straßenseite
siehst du zwei
Mädels laufen.
Und auf einmal kommt
von hinten so ein Typ angesprintet,
haut der einen auf den
Kopf, schnappt sich die Tasche und rennt
weg. Und man denkt sich
so... Frankfurt?
Und...
Naja...
Ich kacke das da so an helllichtem Tag
auf offener Straße.
Aber noch viel besser,
noch viel besser.
Als der losgerannt ist, hat sie ihm hinterher
geschrien. Karl, ich glaube es war Karl.
Karl, was machst
du?
Das heißt, die kannten sich. Die wussten, wer das war.
Und dann...
Alter Leute, ihr seid so fertig dort.
Der Wahnsinn. Ihr müsst einfach zur
Polizei gehen und sagen, guck mal, der Karl hat
mich überfallen. Ich weiß sogar, woran er wohnt.
Die kennen sich, ja? Die sind
ganz dicke.
Wahrscheinlich geht ihr noch nicht mal zur Polizei.
Wahrscheinlich geht ihr nachher beim Karl vorbei
und sagt, hier gib mal die Tasche wieder.
Die sind so fertig in Frankfurt.
Unglaublich. Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Und gerade diese Ecke hier unten,
ja? Diese hier.
Niederstraße, Moselstraße,
Niederstraße und hier vorne Taunusstraße.
Aber gerade das hier unten, das ist wirklich
absolut der... Das ist richtig
Frankfurter Ghetto. Also wenn es in Frankfurt
eins gibt, dann diese Ecke
hier unten. Das ist auch das Mosel-Eck.
So die ekligste Kneipe von außen,
die ich... Ich war da noch nie drinnen.
Die sieht von außen schon so eklig aus,
dass ich da nie reingehen würde.
Na gut, wie dem auch.
Sei. Genug Frankfurt Bahnhofs.
Bahnhofsviertel-Stories.
So. Übrigens wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist,
was auch ein Legacy-Feature ist? Oh, Moment.
Ich muss ja Game Capture
machen, sonst funzt das Ganze ja nicht.
Dort mal Abonnenten treffen.
Genau. So.
Wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist, was auch
Legacy-Feature ist?
Wenn ihr hier drauf geht und wollt die Waffe
modifizieren, ja? Und ihr sagt jetzt,
hm, eigentlich will ich
das Ding hier komplett rauslöschen wieder,
dass es gar nicht drinsteht.
Geht nicht. Es gibt...
Es gibt keinen Button.
Es gibt keinen Button, um Attachments
wieder zu entfernen.
Legacy-Feature. Braucht man nicht.
Das war ja auch nicht im Scope.
Äh, komm.
Ich bin heute mal... Komm, wir spielen heute mal tatsächlich
mit irgendeinem... Nicht... Ihr wisst,
ich bin großer Ironside-Enjoyer.
Großer
Ironside-Enjoyer.
Aber... Gucken wir mal, was besser ist.
Aber wir machen
heute mal. Wir machen heute mal tatsächlich...
einen, äh, einen Scope
drauf. So, habe ich irgendwas ordentliches
schon unlockt? Übrigens, das ist normal.
Das hat anscheinend keine Musik im Menü.
Weiß auch nicht, warum.
Trommelmagazin brauchen wir noch.
Okay.
Pogu. Ach, alles Müll brauchen wir nicht.
Gut. So, lassen wir
mal so.
So, was probieren wir denn sonst noch aus?
Also, ich hab jetzt für mich, wenn gar nichts läuft,
wenn gar nichts läuft, kann ich die
SMGs rausholen. Damit geht eigentlich immer was.
Ansonsten, die neue Waffe, die ist auch
relativ nice. Was können
wir denn machen? Komm, wir probieren mal.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Schneiber.
VK.
Schneiber
spielen wir nicht. Das sieht eher aus, wie
eine Submachine Gun, oder?
Was ist eine Submachine Gun?
Megasin-Size?
Max-Size? 30?
Utility.
Nein, nein, Auto-Shotgun.
So was, so was.
Leute, übrigens, das ist alles, ne?
Mehr gibt's nicht.
Also, muss ich mal vorstellen,
es passt quasi, ohne
wirklich zu scrollen, alles
an Waffen-Selection, ein Jahr nach
Release immer noch alles hier unten auf einem Bildschirm.
Habt ihr mal, nur mal so,
ich weiß, es ist ein ganz, ganz
doofer Vergleich.
Aber ich muss jetzt einfach mal bringen.
Habt ihr mal von Dota 2
die Heldenauswahl gesehen?
Das erschlägt
dich förmlich. Das sind mittlerweile irgendwie
125, okay, das gibt's auch 10 Jahre, oder?
So schon. Aber, es ist halt
auch was, wo du Zeug auswählen kannst.
Und dazu gibt's auch viel, viel mehr. Und hier
passt halt alles, was da unten ist, was
ich unlocked habe.
Epi 29, keck.
Ähm, was muss man machen, um die
M16 zu unlocken?
Ach, hier, da oben. Was muss man machen?
Kill and Assists with
Underbarrel. Ich muss Noob-Tuben,
um die M16 freizuschalten.
Ernsthaft. Und
Kills und Assists
mit das Spharmlgl.
Also mit der
SVM Grenade Launcher.
Oh,
fuck, alter.
Muss das wirklich sein,
ja?
Ich muss Noob-Tube-Kills machen.
Na gut, komm her.
Wo ist denn das Ding überhaupt?
Spharmlgl.
Alles klar, auf geht's.
Das ist auch noch so eine
Low-Rate-of-Fire-Crap-Weapon.
Was ist denn das hier? Ist der Noob-Tube da schon
immerhin, immerhin ist der Noob-Tube
standardmäßig dabei.
Mag-Size 20 ist komplett für'n
Bobbes. Ich hab das Ding
noch nie gespielt.
Underbarrel-Shotgun. Oh ja, das wär
nice. Zählt das auch?
Äh, Zack, ich will das
customizen. Visier?
Visier? Ich hab den noch nie gespielt.
Okay, komm.
Noob-Tube-Unlock.
Auf geht's.
Ähm,
wie war das? Rechtsklick? Rename?
Übrigens, Hauptmenü hat keinen Sound. Das ist nicht so, dass
der fehlen würde. Confirm.
So, was machen wir denn sonst noch?
Secondary.
Ne, zu viel PP-Ge-Aim.
Die ist, ach, die ist
Single-Fire. Die sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Seriously?
Das gibt ganze fünf Pistolen?
Ernsthaft?
Ich dachte eigentlich, mittlerweile ist mehr, aber okay.
Anscheinend nicht.
So, Med-Pack.
Med-Dings. Proxy-Sensor.
Einmal wieder Frack mit.
So, auf geht's.
Zack.
Rush.
So, wir müssen gleich mal kurz gucken, wie das Sound ist.
Ich balle mal kurz ein bisschen in der Gegend rum
und ihr müsst mir sagen, ob das so passt.
Weil Windows und Sound-Settings,
ich hab das zwar eingestellt,
äh, der Sound kommt schon noch.
Wartet mal ab.
Okay, ein bisschen lauter kann ich glaube ich jetzt schon machen.
Ja, ja doch, das Sound ist doch
alles da.
Ach ja, vielleicht sollte ich VoIP ausschalten.
Wenn ich nämlich VoIP anhabe,
laber ich
HAUER CLASS RUSH.
Okay, das ist gut zum testen.
Das ist gut zum testen.
Baller ich ein bisschen in der Gegend rum.
Ähm, ich muss VoIP ausschalten,
sonst schwätze ich die Leute im Game zu.
Falls es standardmäßig keinen Push-to-Talk hat.
Ich trau denen ja alles zu.
Spiel hängt.
Übrigens wisst ihr was?
In MW2 2022
kann man sogar
die Loadouts
und sowas angucken.
Im Respawn-Bildschirm
und sowas.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Achso, kann man hier auch.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz schauen.
Wie mach ich denn hier?
Settings.
Wo sind denn die Settings?
Options.
Äh, Sound.
VoIP, VoIP, VoIP, VoIP.
Aus.
Ähm.
Ach, deswegen hab ich keine Musik.
Lul.
Die ausgeschaltet hab.
Wo könnte VoIP sein?
Bei Voice Chat? Wo ist denn Voice Chat?
Wo?
Ach, da!
Alter, meine Güte.
Voice Chat aus.
Das ist aber auch wirklich kacke zu sehen.
Ich komm, nee, ich noobtube
nicht, klar. Lass mal hier.
Irgendwie was halbwegs sinnvolles.
machen.
Aber Our Class, ich glaub Our Class geh ich wirklich
gleich wieder.
So, den da.
Our Class geh ich gleich wieder raus.
So, Lautstärkentest.
Scheint, scheint okay zu
sein, oder?
Müsste, müsste eigentlich ganz gut passen.
Ja, es dürfte auch nicht ruckeln
und so. Müsste eigentlich alles passen.
Wobei man bei dem Game nie weiß. Also bei dem Game
kann's auch durchaus sein. Sag mal
Spawn? Spawn-Rape will ich grade.
Sag mal.
Oh, werden die grade gespo...
Ah, die Runde hat erst angefangen.
Kack. Oh, leck.
Ruckel, Stelz. Was ist hier los?
Oh, da unten läuft
was. Nee, nee, nee.
Oh, da ist ein Tank.
Ach, ich vergaß.
Man kann ja gar nicht spotten.
Spotten fun...
Funzt ja gar nicht richtig.
Kann man, kann man an den Baum
crappeln? Oh, das ist ne schlechte
Idee. Da bin ich total exposed.
Sieht das Game
immer so matschig aus?
Ich seh mir grad die Vorschau an.
Ja.
Sieht es. Die Vorschau ist in Ordnung.
Die Container...
Ja, die Map wurde noch nicht überarbeitet.
Die ist noch im Ursprungszustand.
Und ist dementsprechend relativ
containerfrei, aber halt schlecht.
Ich mein, die haben's geschafft, innerhalb
von einem Jahr zwei Maps zu überarbeiten.
Es ist halt so, das Game hatte
eh schon kaum Maps zu release.
Und die Überarbeitung dauert halt auch drei Stunden.
Äh, drei Stunden.
Drei Jahre. Drei Stunden.
Ja, so ungefähr drei Stunden hätte da ein fähiger
Map-Designer für gebraucht, das Ganze zu.
Alter,
sehr faire Map.
Ja, ich kann nicht weiter, Leute. Guck mal,
wenn ich hier weiter laufe, dann ist es out.
Es gibt nix, was ich machen kann
gerade. Die stehen im Spawn und kommen
nicht raus.
Außer, dass sie mich gleich snipen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Random bin, genau. Chat,
wusstet ihr, dass ich noch nie in einer Wüste war?
Okay.
Pepega Aim,
Ausrufezeichen.
Wir bräuchten ein Pepega Aim
Counter, was haltet ihr davon?
Oh, dass man
Ausrufezeichen Pepega Aim machen kann.
Im Chat.
Und dann kann ich am Ende des Streams
gucken, wie oft ich Pepega
Aimed habe.
Oh, Chat, eine Frage.
Könntet ihr mal kurz
in der Bitrate gucken, vom
Stream, ob das 7900
Mbits sind?
Müsste.
Müsste 7900 sein.
Alter.
Spawn, Spawnrape
direkt in der ersten Rushrunde.
Das geht ja schon gut los.
Ist da oben einer drauf?
Nö,
der lebt gar nicht.
Warte mal auf Simon.
Was soll ich machen?
Oh,
Ausrufezeichen für Pepega Aim.
Schwankt zwischen 7700 und 8300.
Ja, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was tatsächlich
an der Rush, ich muss die wirklich mal
loben jetzt. Wisst ihr was an der Rush Playlist
wirklich nice ist?
Die Bad Company 2 Maps sind
zum größten Teil drin.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Die Maps, die drin sind,
die sind zum größten Teil in der Rush
Playlist.
Boah, Alter, was laggt das so?
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gatchibass, jawoll.
Diffused, easy.
Boah, ich werde sogar
revived. Welche Grafikeinstellung
ist das? Zum größten
Teil low? Ich muss mal meinen
Motion Sensor schmeißen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Weggesprengt.
Vergiss nicht zu Noobtube.
Ich habe nicht die Noobtube-Klasse.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Die Map ist eh absolute Abfuck.
Wir switchen auf Noobtube.
Wie wählt man den überhaupt aus?
Ähm.
X.
Okay.
Guck mal da.
Jetzt wird er genoobtubed.
Übrigens, diese Mikroruckler sind normal.
Die habe ich auch.
Weiß nicht warum.
Habe ich auf den anderen Maps nicht gehabt.
Das war's.
Da kommt was.
Achtung.
Das Auto.
Massive Noobtube.
Massive.
Ne, war nix.
Da muss ich meine MW2-One-Man-Army.
Erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Noobtube-One-Man-Army.
Meine MW2-2009-Skills wieder rausholen.
Ist das das gleiche Hochhaus mit der gleichen Textur?
Ja.
Das da zumindest.
Das andere nicht.
Aber ja, die ist, also die Map ist nicht sonderlich, ähm, mit, wie soll man sagen, mit, mit Hingebung
für's Liebe zum Detail gemacht.
Nice.
Munition leer.
Pogge.
Das ist halt mal richtig reudig jetzt, wenn ich das nur fürs Noobtuben habe.
Ich glaube, das mache ich nicht im Stream.
Das ist richtig blöde.
20 Schuss, man.
Was willst du denn damit anfangen?
Ach, das ist die Map, wo die ganzen Heli...
Trolls wieder unterwegs sind.
Das ist ein bisschen die Sky...
Ja, Skyline von Frankfurt in 300 Jahren.
Wenn das mit globaler Erwärmung so weitergeht.
Übrigens, die sind blöd, die alle zurückfliegen sollen.
Gut ist.
Ich renne jetzt einfach zurück.
Weil ich gehe einfach sterben.
Easy.
Tank!
Ah!
Gehst du weg hinter mir, Mann?
Ich Noobtube nicht.
Jetzt war ich...
Ich war in einer Wüste, ja?
Jetzt...
Jetzt müsste ich eigentlich das Genshin-Placement machen.
Könnte ich sagen.
Dass ich schon eine...
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich geil fand?
Irgendein Typ hat mich gefragt unter dem Video.
Was ist dein Lieblings-Genshin-Waifu?
Da habe ich geschrieben Venti und irgendwie hat es keiner gecheckt.
Es sind keine Genshin-Kenner hier am Start.
Wenn man immer so...
Wenn man immer nur die neuesten drei Maps spielt, macht das Spiel echt korrekt.
Also, das hier ist gut mit den neuen Maps.
Und wenn Bad Company 2 Maps kommen, dann ist das auch ziemlich nice.
Aber...
Anscheinend kommen ja...
Oh Gott, die Palme, Mann.
Aber anscheinend kommen ja sehr selten Bad Company 2 Maps.
Wait, ist das nicht...
Endlich war einer, der es gecheckt hat, Alter!
Venti ist ein Typ, genau.
Gab es wenigstens genug Kohle?
Weiß nicht, ob ich irgendwas unterschrieben habe, dass ich es nicht erzählen darf, aber ja, ja.
Sonst hätte ich es auch nicht gemacht.
Äh, okay.
Sonst hätte ich das nicht gemacht.
Gäbe es nicht genug Kohle.
Glaub, wir müssen mal zu B rüber.
Erinnern ihr euch noch dran?
Es gab Zeiten, da kamen Elite-Soldaten über so einen Zaun drüber.
Was?
Was ist da drüben?
Legacy-Feature, alles.
Alles Legacy-Feature.
Also anscheinend haben die sich jetzt ein bisschen auf A eingeschossen, wie es aussieht.
Hä?
Das hast du dir so gedacht, Pantsman, hier.
Musst mich mal kurz verdrücken, dass der Panzer mich nicht platt macht.
Hallo?
Panzer?
Mal gucken, ob da einer rausspringt.
Komm, komm.
Wir rennen dem jetzt hinterher und hoffen, dass da einer respawnt und rausspringt.
Spotten geht...
Da oben sind sie schon.
Ich sehe sie, ich sehe sie.
Oh, oh, oh, das war blöd.
Da waren sie schon.
Ich habe sie eben schon da drüben gesehen, ja.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Fuck.
Oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Prage, prage, chat.
Prage, prage, prage, prage, prage.
Nice.
Easy.
Und jetzt ist B am Start.
Kommen wir in YOLO.
YOLO-Time.
Nee.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Achtet mal.
Alter.
Diffuse Champ.
Und er drückt weiter E.
Massive.
Oh, oh.
Ich habe die Waffe geswitcht.
Ja.
Vielleicht gewinnt...
Oh, nee, da ist ein Heli drüber.
Ich spawn lieber wieder rein.
Bis ich, ich glaube, wiederbelebt ist.
Wie?
Alter, eben waren da noch Leute.
Keck, wait.
Eben waren da noch drei Leute.
Oh, ich trommere rum.
Sind die gerade alle verreckt?
Oder...
Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist halt an Our Class so.
Generell an vielen der unüberarbeiteten klassischen Maps richtig pepega.
Diese ganze Heli-Stell-Scheiße da.
Weiß ich genau, von wo da auf mich geschossen wird.
Wie?
Moment.
Wir haben gewonnen?
Easy.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Sekunde.
Ich muss jetzt immer umschalten, dass ich Emotes einblenden kann.
Das ist einfach.
Das ist auch ziemlich dumm.
Easy.
Easy as a fuck.
Weil halt Game Fullscreen.
Es gibt übrigens keine Cringe-Anzeigesprüche mehr.
Invite.
Klar, wenn du mitspielen willst.
Ich invite dich.
Continue.
Übrigens, eins habe ich auch noch nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, Return to Menu, dann fliege ich aus dem Matchmaking.
Wenn ich einfach nur mir diesen Bildschirm...
...für 20 Sekunden angucke, dann geht's weiter.
Was natürlich ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil es passiert einfach 20 Sekunden lang nichts.
Und übrigens, zu unlocken gibt es nicht wirklich auch was.
Und man kann sich Dinger nicht mal angucken, die man hier unlocken kann.
Was jetzt?
Noch mal Hourglass.
Okay.
Fatal und Serious Max, ich invite euch.
Noch mal Hourglass.
Okay, wir machen die Attack.
Wir machen eine Hourglass-Attack-Runde.
Ich invite euch gerade mal im...
...im Ladebildschirm.
Squad Voice Chat Active.
Sollte eigentlich nicht so sein, weil...
Kann ich euch hinzufügen irgendwie?
Hm.
Social?
Habt ihr irgendwie einen Plan?
Kann man hier Leute hinzufügen, wenn man...
Ah, Tab.
Tab, Social.
Fatal ist am Start und das Serious Max ist am Start.
Hoffentlich funktioniert das jetzt.
So.
Jetzt zeigen wir denen mal hier, wie durchgerusht wird.
Kann man?
Ich hab die Map so gut wie nie gespielt.
In Rush kann man hier außen rumlaufen.
Hab ich auch nicht vor, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil, naja, Hourglass ist schon so immer grausam.
Und in Rush ist die auch nicht wirklich gut.
Wobei ich finde, es ist so gut wie alles besser in Rush.
Mag daran liegen, dass das mal mit Abstand...
...Favorite-Spielmodus ist.
Guck mal, pass mal auf.
Sneaky-Stelz.
Massive-Stelz.
Guck mal, die checken es wieder nicht.
Kackel.
Äh, Moment, ist das unten?
Äh, wait a minute.
Wo ist denn das?
Muss ich da hier runter, oder wie?
Achtung, lege Champ.
Lege Champ.
Versteck, versteck.
Versteck Champ.
In der Eck.
Die kommen ja von da.
So, mal kurz den Motion-Sensor hin.
Da ist er schon, der erste.
Auf, komm um die Ecke.
Ich weiß, dass du da stehst.
Komm um die Ecke.
Ich mache jetzt die MW...
Null.
Die MW2-Taktik.
Einfach ab-Aim des Todes.
Ich höre da was.
Achtung.
Oder auch nicht.
Pass mal auf.
Ah.
Ach, hier kann man nicht raus.
Ach, hier kann gar keiner herkommen.
Nice, nice, nice.
Kann man hier durchkrabbeln?
Krabbeln?
Krabbeln-Stelz.
Guck mal hier.
Durchkrabblos.
Ach so.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Massive Krabblos.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, hinter mir.
Haha.
Monka.
Prone Champ.
Ja.
Richtig am Bashen.
So muss das sein.
Okay.
Rätseln wird mich hier wahrscheinlich in der Ecke keiner.
Ich lege ja wirklich komplett.
Guckt mal hier.
Da geht's.
Esther.
So muss das sein.
Legehenne war unterwegs.
Der M-Com Sound ist übrigens auch doof.
Wir machen Flank.
Flank Champ wieder.
Gachi Bass von der Seite.
In der Hoffnung.
Die haben uns noch nicht gecheckt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nee, da kann nix herkommen.
Okay.
YOLO.
Direkt, direkt raus.
Oh, die sehen mich.
Also, wenn die mich nicht sehen, sind sie richtig hängengeblieben.
Richtige PP-Gas.
Oh, das war ziemlich doof.
Ich muss mich kurz verpissen.
Oh, haha.
Genugtum, Mann.
Bumm.
Lull.
Einfach blubb und weg ist er.
Können wir dieses komische Ding jetzt mal, please.
Können wir das...
Das Timer kurz planen.
Und, und die Legehähne jetzt mal durchziehen.
Auf, spring vor mir runter, Alter.
Die Legehähne.
Auf, gib ihm.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Bumm, Dingsbums.
Da bumm.
Oh, Alter.
Wie viele sind da hinten?
Heck.
Pfff.
Det...
Detge.
Nicht die M4.
Die M16 gibt's zum Unlocken.
Danke, Vettel.
Die M16 gibt's zum Unlocken. Danke, Vettel.
Die M16 gibt's zum Unlocken.
Achtung.
Kack.
Hehehe.
Lull.
Alter.
Streckt doch, please, noch mehr euren...
Eure...
Alter.
Jetzt...
Was ist mit denen los?
Hahaha.
Streckt noch mehr eure Köpfe raus, Mann.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Weg.
Vettel, ich kann dich nicht ho...
Oh, jetzt, jetzt.
Moment, jetzt bist du wieder da.
Achtung.
Massive...
Reva...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nein.
Ah.
Hätte funktionieren können.
Moment, wir haben das M-Com immer noch nicht.
Ernsthaft?
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
MVP.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz ein Stückchen weg hier.
Das ist bisschen...
Biss...bisschen zu viel los hier.
Alter.
Oh, oh, ich brenne.
Ich brenne.
He, Flame Champ.
Please.
Können wir das Ding jetzt einfach mal legen und, und dann irgendwie gucken, dass es durchgeht?
Oh, nee, oder?
Auf.
Ich brauch deine Waffe.
Na gut.
Sag mal, warum fliegt...ist das verbuggt?
Warum geht das nicht?
Warum ist...ist das M-Com?
Ist das M-Com kaputt?
Ich glaube, das M-Com ist defekt.
Leute, das M-Com ist kaputt.
Das...
Das ist seit fünf Minuten.
Tut das...tut das schon...
Tut das schon blinken?
Bugged.
Nice.
Na geil.
Sehr schön.
Ein buggedes M-Com.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind.
Excellent.
Nice.
We are running low on troops.
Naja, gut.
Alter, ist das kaputt wieder, das Game, man.
Ammo.
Gib mir Ammo.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wollte ich verhältert.
In der Hoffnung.
Ah, nope.
Wie kann das bitte sein?
Ich finde, das müssten wir jetzt mal in der E-Mail an den Support in Schweden schreiben.
Und fragen, Dice, könnt ihr uns bitte erklären, wie das sein kann?
Und dann antworten die, ach, das wussten wir ja gar nicht.
Aber jetzt, weil der Max uns geschrieben hat und der Twitch-Chat immer so nett ist bei Max,
jetzt fixen wir das.
Okay.
Das haben die dann rein uns zu verdanken, dass das gefixt wird.
99, 59, 0.
Also, Chat.
Wir schreiben nachher eine Mail an Dice.
Auf Schwedisch.
Dass sie das auch verstehen.
Und wir schreiben Feedback so, wie man Feedback an Dice schreiben muss.
Nämlich, dass es ein amazing Game ist, wenn wir so much fun haben,
while playing and greatest game of the century and we are very grateful for making this game.
So, und man muss, man muss Dice, weil die, die, die bekommen sonst kompletten Nervenzusammenabruf,
äh, Zusammenbruch, wenn du gleich anfängst zu flamen.
Also, du musst erst mal übelst schleimen, das habe ich auch bei diesen Events gesehen.
Sag mal, ist es komplett?
Leute, ist das eine TDM-Runde jetzt?
Wir haben null Tickets.
Es ist bugged.
Hahaha.
Ich fasse es nicht mal.
Oh, okay.
Leute, ich zieh uns raus.
28 Kills.
Ich zieh uns raus.
In die Lobby wieder.
Das ist ein, das ist ein endloses, ein endloses Spawn, Spawnrape TDM jetzt geworden.
Okay, komm.
Ähm, kann man liefen mit dem gesamten Team?
Zieht das die Leute?
Wisst ihr, ob das die Leute mit rauszieht?
Probieren wir mal.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Nur Solo.
Ja, aber wir haben Royal Lion haben wir freigeschaltet.
Leute, guckt mal.
Dieses Ding.
Das war natürlich schon mal enorm wichtig, dass wir da dieses Ding jetzt freigeschalten.
Next Reward.
Uiuiui.
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich gar nicht so schlecht.
So, Social.
Sirius, Max, Inviten.
Leute, ich kann euch nicht inviten.
Ihr müsst rausgehen.
Invite geht nicht, solange die schon in der Party drinne sind.
Ist auch ein geiles System, oder?
Ähm, so.
Ach, jetzt ist Endscreen.
So, jetzt ist Endscreen.
Moment, da kann ich ja wieder bei euch reinjoinen.
War ich da bugged?
War ich da verbuggt?
Weil jetzt, wo ich rausgegangen bin, ging's wieder.
Chat, meint ihr, ich war verbuggt?
Ich kann euch übrigens nicht...
Ah doch, jetzt kann ich euch joinen.
Ja, join.
Ja, macht mich mal...
Macht mich mal, please, Leader.
Oder soll ich neu aufmachen?
Ich mach neu auf, Leute.
Das checkt Leafparty, oder?
Oder bin ich?
Ah, ne, ich bin.
Alles klar, danke.
Fängt an, wenn man...
Was?
Das kommt davon, wenn man anfängt, JavaScript zu mögen.
Der Zusammenhang erschließt sich mir jetzt nicht so ganz.
Ich hätte jetzt eher an irgendein Kubernetes-Deployment gedacht.
Guck mal, neuer Kubernetes-Cluster im Hintergrund.
Ungefähr so ordentlich würde der auch aussehen.
Ich hab letztens einen Trailer zugesehen,
das sah mir ein bisschen vom Hipster-Style so nach Apex aus.
Nach manchen Apex-Wir-sind-so-cool-Helden-Trail.
Ah, Stranded, die neue Map.
Sehr schön. Die ist wirklich nice.
Im Vergleich zu vielen anderen.
Also das muss man ihnen lassen.
Ich mein, das ist auch komplette Container-Map wieder,
aber das ist echt in Ordnung.
Ist es in der EA Play Subscription drin?
Das ist eine gute Frage, weiß ich gar nicht.
Oh, wir verlieren gerade. Nice, GG.
Aber das ist nur erste Base.
First. First Base.
Pass mal auf jetzt.
Six Head. Six Head Play.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es nicht klappt.
Okay, es klappt nicht. Gucken zu viele Gegner schon.
Six Head.
Uff!
Alter, ich wurde gerade wieder...
Ne, ich wurde gesniped.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wurde gerade wieder noobtubed.
Aber ich wurde gesniped.
Jawoll, lass mich hier hin.
Ihr wisst, ich defende eigentlich nicht...
What the fuck?
Nicht so gerne.
Ich bin am liebsten off-attack bei Rush.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, da muss ich weg.
Guck mal, wie viele da uns gegenüberstehen.
Spam, spam, spam.
Oh, richtig schön PP-Guard, aber noch erwischt.
Oh, da sniped mir in den Ass, Clay.
Oh, da ist sie wieder.
Oh!
Busy viele.
Okay, respawn. Hier rettet mich eh keiner.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, es gibt wirklich
einen schönen Flank-Weg
in dem Schiff.
Falls ich da irgendwo hinkomme.
Oh, jetzt weg.
Nein, nein, nein, nein,
ihr killt mich jetzt nicht.
Es gibt einen schönen Flank-Weg
und ich weine nicht übers Dach,
sondern hintenrum.
Durchs Hintertürchen sozusagen.
Oh, es laggt.
Es laggt.
Es laggt, krass.
Es laggt, krass. Ich kann nicht mal aufhören zu schießen.
Huge lag.
Hier.
Hier ist der beste.
Also, das muss ich euch dann als Attacker zeigen.
Hier ist der beste Flank-Weg, Leute.
Hier rum.
PP-Guard.
Massive PP-Guard.
Kekkel.
Ich hoffe, die haben mich noch nicht gesehen.
Doch, die haben mich gesehen.
Okay, ich muss mal ins Schiff rein,
dann drehe ich schon die Action.
Und zack.
Also, der Flank-Weg ist außen rechts wirklich am besten.
Da kannst du nämlich, wenn du außenrum flankst,
hier kommst du nämlich nicht hoch, nur als Website,
kannst du hier rein oder ganz außen durch,
was die wahrscheinlich gemacht haben.
Ich hoffe, es aimt keiner dahin.
So.
Da müssen wir jetzt trotzdem mal kurz gucken
auf Bravo Objective.
Da gibt's,
das ist nämlich quasi der Copernetis-Cluster
des Schiffes hier.
Alter, das sitzt da oben drauf
mit seiner Sentry-Gun.
Sonst hat er nichts besseres zu tun,
als sich da oben mit der Sentry-Gun hinzukampen.
So, jetzt, ich wollte die eigentlich
von hinten ein bisschen aufrollen.
So, wir gehen auf die andere Seite.
Weil da kann man runter
droppen. Das ist der Flank-Weg.
Alter, das laggt, oder?
Ich droppe Frames.
Oder?
Droppe ich Frames?
Oder sieht das bei mir nur in der Vorschau so aus?
Oh, oh, das war blöd.
Okay. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wo die Gegner sind.
Wir schmeißen mal hier mal in Motion.
Motion. Ach, sind die da?
Oh.
Da scheint nichts mehr zu sein.
Ja, da oben retzt mich niemand.
Installier mal Optifine.
Ist Optifine nicht dieses Minecraft
Shader-Mod?
Oh, oh. Achtung.
Play, play. Massive.
Massive-Higher-IQ-Play.
Pass mal auf.
Und jetzt, und jetzt.
Ne, hat nicht
funktioniert. Aber
kann's ja mal probieren.
Und Pepega. Wir brauchen ein
Pepega-Aim-Ausrufezeichen-Bot-Command.
Wart mal.
Es ist mir grad zu viel. Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Boomer, Boomer alt.
Ah, Massive-Aim.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Krass, krass ist das Scheibenwischer-Aim.
Überhaupt.
Okay.
Oh, so dumm, Alter. Ich treff nix.
Ich bin so schlecht.
Guckt euch das mal an. Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Aber.
Äh, was wollt ich sagen?
Ah, mit 38.
Ist das okay?
Vielleicht landet's ja im Game Pass.
Ich hab eh keine Ahnung, Leute. Warum ist das
überhaupt nicht im Game Pass?
Leuchtet mich nicht so ganz ein.
Oder nicht im Game Pass.
Im EA.
In diesem EA-Abo.
Wo ist er hin?
Der ist doch zur anderen Bombe durchgerannt,
der Dude, oder?
Der ist doch garantiert zu A durchgerannt, Leute.
Gleich blinkt A.
Ne, da liegt er.
Da geht an A doch nix.
EA...
Ach, der ist... Ja, aber das ist halt...
Es ist halt richtig blöd, dass das nicht drinnen ist.
Warum ist das
nicht drinnen?
Weil dann hätte es wirklich ein bisschen bessere Spielerzahlen.
War das der Gegner?
Auf der anderen Seite ist auch einer.
Alter, ich hab 4 gedrückt.
Er heilt sich einfach nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Der hat sich einfach nicht geheilt.
Pass auf, wir machen jetzt flank.
Noobtubed.
Von der Seite genoobtubed.
Warum?
Warum ist das ne Challenge?
Ah, shit.
Was dieses EA-Abo ist, auch
im Gamepass kann alle EA-Games
zocken, bis auf 2042.
Ja, aber warum ist es nicht drinnen, ist ja die Frage.
What? Monka.
Alter.
Ich werd nur noch genoobtubed gerade.
Die machen alle diese dämliche
M16-Challenge, Mann.
Was ist das?
Noobtubed tot, noobtubed tot.
Mach das jetzt auch gleich.
BF20 verkauft doch sowieso niemand.
Sagen wir mal, es ruckelt doch ein bisschen.
Oder bin ich jetzt total...
Ich seh das gerade auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm, aber es ist
keine Frames, Mist und nichts.
Ich glaub, das liegt an meinem Vorschau-Rechner,
der einfach nicht klarkommt damit.
Ich muss gleich mal auf dem Handy Probe gucken.
Passt mal auf.
Ne, hier gehts noch nicht rauf.
Alles gut?
Dann ist es nur die Vorschau, die ruckelt.
Was zum...
Ah, das ist über Range nicht so geil.
Das ist über Range nicht so geil.
Massive Aim.
Geht ab.
So, die kriegen jetzt mal diesen Motion-Sensor.
Das wackelt aber auch ganz schön.
XDR, richtig.
Da muss ich ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Die kommen nicht wirklich auf den Spot gerade.
Kommt mal, da oben wollte einer fliegen.
Ich hör da unten was laufen.
Ah, weggeschneibert.
In der letzten Base muss ich sagen...
Gehen wir mal auf Sub-Machine-Gun.
Weil da ist ziemlich, meistens,
Zumindest ziemlich Close-Quarter-lastig.
Das Serious Markster machts alle alleine weg.
Gucken, ob die überhaupt vorwärts kommen,
so weit, dass sie in der Base mal landen.
Nope, in the Korb.
Der will mich noobtuben, Alter. Habt ihr's gesehen?
Habt ihr's gehört? Der hat direkt runter genoobtubt.
Kommt noch mehr.
Ja, geil.
Alter, die sind ja dran.
Nein, schieß mir nicht in Bobbes.
Container-Field. Ja, ist so.
Ist so.
Das Spiel ist wirklich...
Wenn ihnen nix eingefallen ist,
was sie wohin klatschen können, dann haben sie einfach
gesagt, ja, wir machen entweder so ein paar
Absperrungshütchen, oder wir machen
paar Steine, oder wir machen paar LKWs,
oder wir machen Container, oder wir machen LKWs
mit Container obendrauf.
Achtung.
Lege Henne.
Nice.
Oh, oh, da war was.
Ach, Moment. Ich hab ne Frag-Dump...
Ne.
Entschärfungs-Champ. Nein.
Mehr Container. Oh, oh.
Das ist mir ein bisschen viel los hier.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh. Fuck. Wie komm ich denn
wieder runter?
Gar nicht.
Hast du schon mal Warzone ausgespielt?
Äh, ausprobiert. Ja, hab ich.
Ich hab sogar...
Relativ... Also, für meine Verhältnisse
relativ viel Warzone probiert.
Oh, oh.
Shit, Alter. Ich hab sogar schon
relativ viel Warzone für meine Verhältnisse ausprobiert.
Irgendwie... Jetzt hab ich ja 120 Stunden oder so.
Aber ich komm... Ich weiß
nicht. Irgendwie ist Battle Royale einfach nicht
meins. Nicht nur
Container. Warum immer wieder eine Map mit einem
Chef? Wahrscheinlich, weil die schon Assets hatten.
In Form von, ähm...
Containern und sich gedacht haben,
okay, was können wir für eine Map bauen,
wo Container möglichst
natürlich wirken? Und da haben sie gesagt,
aha, wir machen einfach eine Schiffsmap mit
Containerschiffen.
Meine Güte, ey.
Haben wir entschärft? Haben wir entschärft?
Haben wir entschärft?
Oh, Pog!
Jetzt muss ich mich vielleicht mal anstrengen
zur Abwechslung.
Ach, da ist ein...
Meine Güte.
Ich hab überhaupt keine
Orientierung mehr gerade.
Hinter mir.
Ah, shit. Hab die Füße gesehen.
Wolle, danke schön für den Sub.
Könnte das mit Konsolen zusammenhängen?
So ein Grafikthema? Nee.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal
Spiele auf der Xbox 360 an. Die hatten
teilweise vielfältigere
und schönere...
Da war noch ein Gegner gerade.
Ah!
Wo geht's lang?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Vielfältigere und schönere Sachen
als dieses Game.
Ist mir grad zu...
Ah, shit. Ich dachte, man kann irgendwie
vorbeispringen.
Aber A geht.
In Combat.
Schnell rein.
Was sind wir denn hier überhaupt?
Können wir die in den...
Ass bashen?
Die spawnen doch da hinten irgendwo.
Da kommt was reingeflogen.
Fuck. Ich wusste nicht, ob oben oder unten.
Sieht schlecht aus als Battlefield 3 damals.
Ja, das liegt mit daran, dass die Beleuchtung so komisch ist.
Die Beleuchtung ist komisch und...
Easy. Easy win.
Die Beleuchtung ist komisch.
Der Detailgrad ist komisch.
Die Vielfalt der Sachen auf der Map
Ich mein, muss ich mal angucken.
Grand Bazaar.
Viel rudimentärer kann eine Map eigentlich nicht sein.
Paar Straßen, Betonwänder,
ne Brücke oder so.
Aber Grand Bazaar hatte, allein schon auch, dass es ein bisschen Nebel gegeben hat,
Nasse Straßen teilweise.
Hat irgendwie
Lebendiger gewirkt als die
2042 Maps.
Also Größe ist ja wirklich nicht alles.
Die Maps mögen zwar groß sein,
aber...
Was hab ich von großen Maps,
wenn sie einfach nur langweilig sind.
Wie laufen die Runden?
Eigentlich recht gut.
Die Runde war hardcore pepega.
Aber muss auch mal sein.
Wir haben wieder irgendwas progressed.
Und haben jetzt,
Leute wisst ihr,
jedes andere Game, was ich kenne,
mit einem Battle Pass,
da kannst du dann, wenn du was unlockt hast,
das irgendwie anklicken.
Und dir angucken und drehen
und sagen, ich will es gleich equippen und sowas.
Ah!
Eine gescheite Map!
POG!
Was, Max, irgendwelche Tipps für AP2?
Was ist AP2?
Ach, für den Physik, keine Ahnung.
Ach, das ist Abschlussprüfung 2.
Meine Güte, ey.
Mehr, mehr
Abkürzungen, please.
Moin, Lordkiller.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich hab irgendwas übersehen.
Hast du schon mal World War 3 gespielt?
Ja, sogar im Stream.
Das macht tatsächlich Bock, aber es ist halt
wirklich im Anti-Cheat und sonst wie
Dingern und es ist ewig nicht rausgekommen.
Ich hab's mittlerweile wieder deinstalliert.
Ähm,
Lobby buggt, das braucht noch.
Muss noch Leute suchen.
Dann müsste es eigentlich auch
losgehen.
Ne, Lobby ist wirklich buggt.
Versuch mal...
Oh, ja doch, jetzt geht's doch los.
Moment, Max ist tatsächlich raus.
Social.
Wo ist er?
Ne, du bist angeblich in der Party drinnen.
Joints bei dir jetzt?
Wenn nicht, geh mal aus der Party raus
und ich invite dich wieder.
Oh, ne. Bots?
Bots.
Okay.
Ich geh jetzt auf die erste
Base und wenn es
bis dahin nicht aufgefüllt ist
mit echten Spielern...
Alter, ich fahr mit Bots.
Guckt euch das an.
Und guckt euch mal, wie bescheuert
dieses Aim immer noch ist.
Äh, ich hab dich grad invited.
Geht's net?
Ne. Leute, wir müssen raus.
Das ist Bot-Lobby.
Bot-Lobby.
Oh man, Battlefield, please.
Guck mal, jetzt bekriegen sich hier die Bots.
Das hat die...
Nice. Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Von
stprkscosai
wurde ich gewonshotted.
Okay, Leute.
Ich mach die Lobby
neu auf.
Oder machen wir's anders.
Ich joine in ein Game
und dann invite ich euch.
Weil irgendwie scheint's zu buggen,
wenn man mit mehreren Leuten...
Das ist... Muss ich echt mal überlegen.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich
Fail, oder?
Dass ein Jahr nach Release das immer noch so krass
rumbuggt mit Lobbys.
Ich hab die letzten zwei Tage
solo gespielt überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ich bin weder in verbuggten Lobbys
gewesen noch sonstwas.
Aber sobald ich jetzt mit...
Ja, hier, hier.
Mit premade Lobby spiele,
buggt jede zweite Runde.
Discarded.
Ich hätte gerne die ordentlichen Maps.
Sowas wie
Orbital ist beispielsweise
ganz nice jetzt auf Rush.
Oder die
von Season 1,
die Map ist auf Rush auch ganz gut.
Oder die
Map und sowas.
So, Invite kommt. Social.
Ihr seid schon bei mir drinnen, oder wie?
Ach, jetzt hab ich
die Lobby doch mitgenommen?
Okay.
Na gut.
Oh, Megalul.
Oh, links
ist was.
Ey, Grenade Launcher.
Grenade Launcher.
Oh, da sind ganz schön viele.
Oh, die haben sich da aber ganz schön
einverbarrikadiert in diesem Haus.
Das ist glaube ich
Lost.
Ja, na, das geht noch nicht als
Spawnrape durch. Spawnrape ist, wenn jetzt hier
einer dahinter stehen würde.
Übrigens B ist, finde ich, nahezu nicht
gescheit
defendbar.
Aber trotzdem. Wir probieren das mal.
Indem wir...
Oh, da vorne ist ein UAV.
Ey, Leute, ich kann nicht mehr richtig reden.
Ihr wisst schon, was ich meine, gell?
Und der Panzer, das...
Oh, oh, oh, ganz dumm
gewesen, da runter zu springen. Ganz dumm.
Oh, oh!
Meine Güte. Ich wollte
aufs Dach und nicht durchs Fenster.
Letztendlich war es ganz gut, dass
ich durchs Fenster... Ich wollte nicht durchs Fenster.
Kommt da nicht
rein, Leute. Da ist
alles voll.
Nochmal aufs Dach. Dach war gut.
So.
Die sind ziemlich...
Was?
Warum ist der gerade nicht gestorben?
Lul. Da vorne?
Ha! Lul!
So, jetzt stürmen sie. Wir hätten die
in diesem komischen...
In dieser komischen Fabrikhalle einfach verschimmeln
lassen sollen. Jetzt... Oh!
Jetzt stürmen
sie hier auf B drauf. Aber sie haben nur noch
35 Tickets.
Oh, Flank-Action.
Muni.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wo... Ist da oben was?
Auto?
Kurz hier durch... Kurz hier durchstelzen.
Oh, oh!
LA...
LAV
am M-Com.
Das ist schlecht.
Oh, was geht denn mit dem ab?
Wie Belfi
spielt der?
Wo ist er?
GG Eats. Fuck.
Naja. Immerhin cooler Run gewesen.
Bisschen was weggeflankt.
Oh, ne.
Ich... Du wolltest mich... Leute, sorry.
Ich release zu schnell.
Ähm. Nennt man das in dem Spiel überhaupt so?
Nein, ich respawne zu schnell, meine ich.
Releasen, Alter. Das ist so MMO
Sprache von 2000.
Ich bin es nicht gewohnt, dass ich mit Leuten
zusammen spiele.
Releasen, man.
Der Fabian hätte es verstanden, wenn ich gesagt hätte
releasen.
Lebt der Dude noch?
Ja. Aber er hat gelebt.
Chat, was denkt ihr
bis jetzt über das Game?
Was ihr bis jetzt gesehen habt?
Meint ihr, sie haben
in einem Jahr genug geschafft, dass ich das
dass ich das quasi
bisschen seinen schlechten Ruf wieder
wettmachen kann?
Okay, scheint nicht.
Oh, ne.
Ha! So nicht, Kollege.
Diffused Champ.
Easy.
Die Specialists müssen noch entfernt werden, sagt
ihr. Die werden nicht entfernt.
Die werden nicht entfernt.
Ich dachte mir am Anfang auch gar nicht,
dass das so... Also, okay. Muss ich
anders erzählen. Also.
Der Typ sieht aus wie direkt aus Black Ops 3.
Sieht aus wie der eine Typ aus Black Ops 3. Multiplayer.
Also, erstmal
war ich kein Fan von
Specialists am Anfang. Als ich mir dann
ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht habe, muss ich
sagen, doch so schlecht
wie es geredet wurde
und jetzt auch im Nachhinein
immer noch, fand ich
am Anfang gar nicht. Ich fand den Ansatz mit Specialists
prinzipiell nicht verkehrt. Erstens,
weil es eine gute Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit
gibt. Klar, man kann sagen, Monetarisierung
who cares, aber
irgendwie musst du halt, wenn dir das Spiel gefällt,
hoffen, dass es sich langfristig lohnt
für den Hersteller. Ich dachte mir, das ist eine gute
Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit und
nachdem ich dachte,
dass die Specialists quasi
nur Verfeinerungen
der bestehenden
Klassen sind, was sie
streng genommen ja auch sind. Also, ich
glaube, die Specialists sind ja nach wie vor
Engineer, Medic, Recon,
Assault, aber
das, sagen wir mal,
das Ursprungskit
schimmert da halt nicht mehr durch.
Ich dachte ursprünglich halt,
dass beispielsweise
McKay, jeder Typ mit dem
Enterhaken, den ich spiele, das ist
ein Engineer mit einem
Enterhaken. Also, ich hab im Endeffekt
dann mein Engineer-Kit
und hab dann halt ein festes zweites
Gadget. Ja, so ist es irgendwie
auch, aber du kannst trotzdem ja mit jeder Klasse
alles wählen und dementsprechend auch als Engineer
Medipacks und sonst
was, das ergibt dann wieder keinen Sinn.
Die Wingsuit-Tante ist auch tatsächlich
zu extrem gewesen. Die wurde, glaube
ich, genervt mittlerweile und finde ich sogar
ganz sinnvoll, in der sie
glaube ich, ich hab die bis jetzt noch gar nicht
mal ausprobiert,
die zweite Granate weggemacht haben.
Das fand ich ganz gut, weil
gerade die Frag-Grenade, also
die Fragmentation-Grenade,
die zu spammen
war
ziemlich OP. Du konntest ja dann auch noch
einen Motion-Sensor oder irgendwas werfen
oder noch Smoke dabei.
Bringen die irgendwann
einen Server-Browser? Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Okay, okay, okay. Ich weiß,
manche sagen jetzt wieder, Max, es gibt doch einen Server-Browser.
Naja, Leute, es gibt
Portal, es gibt den Portal-Browser,
aber da ist halt keiner drin.
Zu viel PP geaimt, aber
hätte klappen können.
Hätte klappen können.
Alter!
Geh doch mal aus
Geh doch mal aus deinem Loch
da hinten raus, Mann.
Geh aus deinem Loch.
Ich geh da jetzt runter.
Piss dich, Aldo!
360 No Scope.
Oh, werd ich?
Oh, nice, nice, nice. Oh, der ist vorbei gehüpft.
Macht nix. 360 No Scoped.
Fuck.
Ah, wir kriegen das. Zu viel
Legacy-Feature.
So, während die jetzt...
Shit, shit. Oh, daneben ist total viel.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Alter, ich werde hier gerade geaimt
von... Ich muss weg.
Und tschüss. Bunny hoppen!
Weg hier!
Alter, Monka!
Okay, wir machen jetzt
das Play.
Fuck, die sind schon alle down.
Und shooten mir in der Ass.
Vielleicht.
Achtung.
Oh, shit. Fast dran gewesen.
Der Sniper-Typ, Mann.
Der mit der Gold-Sniper.
Der ist richtig gut.
Also, es können keine Cheater sein.
Lasst euch das mal gesagt sein.
Es gibt keine Cheats mehr für das Game.
Weil die ganzen Cheat-Entwickler die Arbeit
und den Support eingestellt haben an Battlefield 2020.
Da wollte ich nicht hin, ich wollte da rein.
Nice, danke. Danke, danke für dieses
Precise-Movement-Spiel.
Ich wollte in den Container rein.
Lohnt sich nicht.
Ja, die haben die Cheat-Entwicklung
eingestellt.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, oder?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, der hat noch mehr PP
geaamt als ich.
Dass der mich nicht gekillt hat.
Lul.
Ach, Mann. Warum drehen die sich auch im falschen Moment um?
Die Runde läuft da gar nicht.
So, nice, nice, nice.
Reinspawn.
Und direkt aufs Dach.
Mensch, bleibt mal da.
Was?
WTF?
Das waren gerade vier Schüsse oder so.
Voll in den Kopf. Aber nein.
Bleiben stehen.
Der Ivan.
Ivan0265, der macht das jetzt. Easy.
Ivan owned.
Ivan pockchamped.
Ey, warum hat der Heal abgebrochen?
The fuck?
Ist halt einfach der Heal abgebrochen.
Äh, okay.
Ey, der Schleiber, Mann.
Der Typ. Der fuckt mich.
Ultra ab.
Der hat mich jetzt schon fünfmal gesniped.
Ich glaub jeder Desk diese Runde.
War der Schleiber, Mann.
Ah, ja.
Oh, oh.
Jetzt wird's aber.
Wird's aber kritisch hier.
Gleich geht's auf.
Ist der Schleiber, Mann, noch da?
Ah, Alter, das Movement, Mann.
Wo ist denn der?
Da.
Das Moved mich da, wo ich überhaupt nicht hinmoven wollte.
Hast du dir Finals angesehen?
Leute, ich muss, wartet mal.
Ich muss mir mal kurz den Trailer davon.
The Finals Trailer.
Das müssen wir uns gleich angucken.
Ich bilde mir ein, dass ich das gesehen hab.
Das ist das von Embark Studios oder wie die heißen.
Also die, die früher mal Dice waren.
Also viele von Dice.
Okay.
P-P-P-P-Pega.
Oh.
Ach, das ist der Typ mit der.
Der Achter.
So geht das aber nicht.
Der Rushmaster muss wieder zuschlagen.
Besser als der Coinmaster.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ein Nebel. Nebelstelz.
Hoffentlich komme ich schnell rüber, bevor die mich erwischen.
Oh, nice, ich werd.
Nebel.
Nebelohrs.
Und jetzt machen wir da vorne noch einen Motion Sensor.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Easy. Auf geht's.
Go, go, go, go, go. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also hier durchzukommen ist schwierig.
Oh, nice.
Huge Razz.
Falsche Richtung.
Massive Razz.
Okay. Achtung, da ist noch einer.
Ich hab den Schatten gesehen.
Fuck. Fast. Fast, Leute.
Jawoll. Alle weg. Alle weg.
Rushed rein.
Vielleicht kriegt noch jemand einen Razz raus.
Massive Pogge.
Ich spekuliere ja, ehrlich gesagt,
drauf, dass es vielleicht
als nächstes wieder einer der guten Maps gibt.
Komm, wir düsen mal hier.
Spawns bei mir rein.
Was macht denn der da?
Wie? Jetzt gib ihm.
Also hier übers Flache
zu kommen ist halt echt...
Da kann an jeder Ecke einer sitzen.
Ziemlich...
...ragwürdig.
Okay.
Wir müssen das anders angehen.
Wir müssen den Stealth-Modus aktivieren.
Warten wir mal.
Warten wir mal, bis der...
Leute.
Six Head.
Pass mal auf. Pass mal auf. Six Head-Modus.
Haha.
Aber immerhin.
Hey, es hätte funktionieren können.
Ja, geil.
Da stehen sie mit der Gatling-Gun am...
Und aimen alles ab.
Was willst du denn da bitteschön machen?
Nice, nice. Spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn.
Da ist ein Gegner.
Was? Ah!
Das Movement macht mich fertig.
Ich will überhaupt nicht an die Leiter.
Disabled.
Ich kann nicht nicht razzen. Sorry.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Hier, Motion-Sensor.
Motion-Sensor, dass wir sehen, wenn was abgeht.
Oh, da ist einer dran an B. Fuck.
Nice, wir haben ihn.
Okay.
So, der erste Ansturm müsste jetzt ja eigentlich weg sein.
Bam.
Und jetzt, wenn sie alle herrennen.
Fuck.
Okay.
YOLO.
Wow.
Okay, jetzt oder nie.
26 Tickets noch.
Ich sehe da nichts. Ich sehe da nichts.
Da hinten ist was.
Achtung, Achtung, gib ihm. Obendrauf muss ich.
Nein, nein. Oh shit.
Shit.
Du kommst hier nicht durch.
Das ist so offen und so flach.
Ich mein.
Okay, mehr als probieren, mehr als probieren.
Geht nicht. Oh shit.
Oh.
Legehände.
Jawoll.
Prege.
Wir haben es.
Meine Güte.
What the fuck.
Was ein Act.
Hätte ich weiter im Island sein bleiben sollen.
Was ein Act, Alter.
Das war ja der Grind.
Fuck.
Alter.
Wie viele wollen wir denn noch killen lassen?
Killer Elite, Mann.
Guckt euch mal an. Der outet das ganze Team aus dieser Ecke.
Killer Elite.
Mensch.
Der stirbt noch nicht mal.
Ah, nein. Ich hab ihn. Okay.
Geht das so?
Nope. Nope. Oh. Hier, was?
Wo sind wir denn hier jetzt gelandet?
Äh.
Bringt das hier was?
Eher nicht, oder? Egal.
Das hat er sich so nicht vorgestellt.
Alter.
Battlefield. Come on.
Please.
Funktionier mal.
Ich will da rauf.
Nee, da geht's auch nicht hoch.
Wird ja immer besser hier.
Wir haben die
Base eingenommen, bis ich's mal irgendwann
auf das Schiff oben drauf geschafft hab.
Achtung.
Massive.
Lege Hände.
Äh.
Nice Spot. Nice Spot.
GGE's. Uh.
Da ist einer dran.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das war's wert.
Jetzt müssen die Leute nur noch runrushen und wir haben's.
Leute, da sind so viele.
Ihr müsst einfach nur das Objective...
Oh, ich werd sogar gerast.
Oh, Grass, Alter. Massive Pog.
So ist das cool.
So mag ich das.
So.
Wenn wir Glück haben.
Geh ich nass.
Ich aim das jetzt einfach ab.
Egal, was passiert.
Shit.
Einer. Okay.
Mehr geht nicht.
Lege Hände.
Aber wir haben uns hier gut
gut eingenistet.
Wir haben viel Respawn, wir haben da...
Äh.
Mit was schieß ich da überhaupt?
Schieß ich da überhaupt?
Ach nee, das ist eine Granate.
Ich check die Fahrzeuge grad nicht.
Ah, ah, ah.
War das ein Spotter?
War das eine Spotter-Position, in der ich war?
Nice.
Oh, ich dachte, es ist vorbei.
Ich dachte, es ist vorbei.
Was haltet ihr von WW3?
Okay, Leute. Das ist jetzt die fünfte Frage im Stream.
Sollen wir
das demnächst nochmal streamen?
WW3?
Ich mein, ich will mir kein Mail.ru
Anti-Cheat installieren, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aber vielleicht...
Ups.
Ich hab gehört, die haben Mail.ru Anti-Cheat
rausgeschmissen.
Und jetzt ist es, ähm...
Mail.China Anti-Cheat.
Es wird wahrscheinlich kein besserer Anti-Cheat...
Oh.
Monka? S?
Wo sind wir?
Oh.
Grapple in place.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also die, die, die, die, ähm...
Ich krieg kein Wort mehr raus.
Die Direction, aus der man
beschossen wird, die Anzeige, ist oftmals
auch nicht...
so ganz...
Patel, ich komme.
Oh nein. Ich komm nicht.
Nice.
Guter Ress.
Ress.
Geretzt.
Lege Hände, lege Hände, lege Hände.
Okay.
Was?
Oh.
Wo kamen der Typ jetzt
noch her?
Oben alles ausgeräuchert
und der Shotgun-Typ
ist da noch. Ich fasse es nicht.
Der Shotgun-Man.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ah, shit.
Okay. Vielleicht haben wir noch ein paar Fahrzeuge
hier zu bieten.
Der Finals wird als
Battlefield-Kinder... Ganz ehrlich, nur, dass es
von ehemaligen DICE-Entwicklern ist,
bin mir da gar nicht so sicher. Komm, wir gehen zu B.
Ich mein,
Finals sieht so über...
Überhaupt nicht aus wie Battlefield.
Und auch alles, was ich gesehen habe,
sah auch nicht aus, als spielte sich wie Battlefield.
Word.
Ha. Kerkel.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Side-Step, Side-Step.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Side-Step, Side-Step.
A.D., A.D.
Das hab ich in Overwatch gelernt. Einfach möglichst
viel A.D., A.D. spammen.
Und dann ist alles gut.
A.D., A.D. spammen.
Ich hab... Ja, ich hör den neben mir.
Okay. Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Stell's, stell's, Champ.
Fuck.
Ah, wusste, dass da noch einer liegt.
Keine Chance. Aber es sind viele Leute
von unserem Team ran.
Bestimmt noch Overwatch 2.
Bestimmt. Das hab ich komplett vergessen.
Overwatch 2 kommt ja am
Dienstag oder so,
gell? Dienstag?
Dienstag?
Oder?
Ah, ah.
4. Oktober, Dienstag.
Ja. Lege Hände. Komm, Leute.
Defend it. Defend it.
Dreh dich um dahinter. Blau. Blau, dreh dich um.
Da steht einer in der Ecke. Alter, White Angel.
Geh ran. Alter, geh ran.
MonkaS, Alter.
Die sind 20 Sekunden
aneinander vorbeigelaufen.
Ich blick hier nicht.
Ist zu viel. Ist zu viel los.
Boomer, Boomer.
Müde Boomer. Es ist spät.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch, Leute.
Zu viel. Auf einmal gerade.
Aber wir sollten A... Oh ne, da geht gerade einer ran.
An A und defused.
Nein, der defused. Der defused.
Ich seh's.
Nein, wir haben's.
Sehr gut.
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Solange die da sind, einfach YOLO.
Ach, wir können noch gar nicht.
Shit.
Aber jetzt. 5 Sekunden und auf geht's.
Abfahrt.
Gutes alte durch...
Charlie Mike.
Was genau ist Charlie Mike?
Oscar Mike kenn ich noch.
Oscar Mike ist on the move.
Das kenn ich noch aus MW2.
Was ist Charlie Mike?
Wer hat das Military Speak drauf?
Alter, was ein...
Was ein mega schlechtes Aim von mir gerade.
Wir gucken uns gleich den Finals Trailer an.
Max, bleib mal oben.
Dass ich bei dir spawnen kann, falls es geht.
Pog. Sehr schön.
Nice. Six Head Team hier am Start.
So mag ich das.
Hi IQ.
Wo sind denn überhaupt die M-Comps hier?
Okay, Achtung, Achtung, passt mal auf.
Nein, so war das nicht geplant.
Ich wollte von oben auf das M-Com springen
und mich dann ranziehen mit dem Enterhaken
weil das macht lustigerweise, wenn man sich von oben nach unten zieht,
keinerlei Falldamage.
Achso, vielleicht sollte ich einfach am Spawn.
Spawnpunkt.
Spawnen.
Oh ne, defused.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir das auch theoretisch nur abaimen.
Und während die da rüber rennen,
können wir doch eigentlich auf B.
Komm, ich probier's mal.
Ahja, sieht gut aus, sieht gut aus, sieht gut aus.
Lege Henne, lege Henne.
Hehehehehe.
Lul.
Passt mal auf, wenn mich hier keiner sieht,
werde ich die alle bashen, die B entschärfen wollen.
Camp, Camp Time.
Aber es will glaube ich gar keiner B entschärfen, kann das sein?
B muss not defused werden.
Easy.
Win.
Lege Henne.
116. Easy.
38.
So mag ich das.
Outpositioned.
Outsixheaded würde ich sagen.
Outstanding Performance, Leute.
Da habt ihr's, ja.
Top 1%
Outstanding Performance.
6 M-Com armed.
6 armed, 3 destroyed.
Massive.
Immortal Strat.
Oder wie heißt der höchste Rang in Valorant?
War das nicht Immortal?
Oder war Valorant der höchste Rang in Valorant?
Nee, Immortal ist es in Dota.
In Dota ist es Immortal, oder?
Nee, das hab ich jetzt durcheinander gebracht.
Wart mal.
Jetzt hab ich's, glaub ich, durcheinander gebracht.
Oscar Mike is on the move.
Ich weiß, aber was ist Charlie Mike?
Das war ja die eigentliche Frage.
Ach, Continuum Mission.
Ah.
Leute, jetzt können wir uns
als erstes mal die überarbeitete
Kaleidoskop-Map angucken.
Ich glaube,
es gibt jetzt einige Container
zu sehen gleich.
Nur so eine Vermutung.
Nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube,
Postchamp. Ich glaube, es gibt ein paar Container.
Oh nee, ist die Lobby wieder
broken?
Arbeitest du aktuell ausschließlich Homeoffice?
Nein. Ich bin auch ein paar Tage in Frankfurt.
Ich hab übrigens am Freitag
Ärger bekommen, weil ich die letzten
drei Wochen nicht oft genug in Frankfurt war.
Dabei ist es gar nicht so, dass ich nicht
wollte. Ich wollte dienstags
hinfahren, zwei Züge
ausgefallen. Dann wollte ich freitags
hinfahren, wieder Bahnabfuck.
Jetzt war ich halt jeweils da nur einen Tag.
Da gab es Ärger
letztens, dass ich zu wenig da bin.
Aber ganz im Ernst, es
juckt mich auch nur am Rande,
weil...
Oh nee, Bot-Match.
Okay, wir warten noch mal kurz,
ob das gleich...
Ich bin da wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr lange.
Also insofern guck jetzt halt,
dass ich das so mache, dass mein Chef nicht so viel Ärger kriegt.
Demnächst
gibt es auch einen neuen
Abteilungsleiter. Vielleicht ändert sich bei dem noch was.
Und ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich bin da eh nicht mal
lange. Es sei denn...
Oh.
Peckel. Das waren alles Bots, sonst wäre ich tot
gewesen. Es sei denn...
Die Firma macht irgendwie noch mal 180 Grad
Kehrtwende.
Okay, es füllt sich
langsam, es füllt sich langsam. Bisschen weniger Bots
am Start.
Ups.
Ich habe Kommissar-Elite gelesen.
Killer-Elite. Ja, okay.
Bots sind fast alle weg.
Alter, ich treffe nicht mal einen Bot, Mann!
Wie schlecht kann man sein?
Wo ist er hin?
Ist einfach verschwunden.
Disarm-Champ.
Ey, ey, ey, ey, ey. Achtung.
Pfeiffer-Time.
Au.
On-Stream-Jobsuche. Wir haben
im Stream schon Jobs gesucht und danach
hatte ich drei Angebote. Eins,
was ich wirklich
cool fand, aber wo sich dann leider
nichts mehr ergeben hat. Da hatte ich
ein Probe...
Ein Probearbeitstag, aber da hatte ich leider
Corona und danach hat sich nichts mehr ergeben.
Oh, ich werde gerast.
Okay.
Der Dark Knight.
Okay. Ich höre da was.
Okay, aus.
Ha!
Das hat er sich... Oh, oh.
Nix, nix wie rauf
hier. Äh, by the way,
ich bin eigentlich blöd. Ich könnte einfach viel öfters
die Muni switchen.
Ja, also wir haben, wir haben schon
On-Stream-Stellenangebote angeschaut und
wahrscheinlich machen wir das demnächst auch wieder. Nido,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Machen wir es demnächst auch.
Es ist immer schön zu wissen, was es sonst so, was es so alles gibt.
Übrigens,
ich halte die ersten zwei Objectives hier für nicht
wirklich haltbar.
Es sei denn, man ist mega viel
dominanter als
das gesamte Gegnerteam.
Hallo? Springen!
Elite-Soldat!
So, jetzt müssen wir hier mal
ein bisschen gucken.
Es wäre übrigens cool, wenn man immer
mit dem gleichen spawnen würde und nicht mit dem
Backup-Magazin.
Da merkt sich immer das Letzte.
Was ziemlich...
Ach, shit!
Ich habe fünf Gegner um mich gehört.
Das ist mir okay. Versuch es mal abzuhauen.
Na gut, meine letzte Runde
richtig hardcore
geownt. Kann ja nicht jede Runde
so sein.
Alter! Mensch, lass mich doch mal heilen!
Die nächsten M-Comps sind schon
einfacher zu defenden in dem Haus
hier. Da hinten das, hier, das da ist
glaube ich. Das ist wirklich nice.
Da gibt es ein paar richtig
Six-Head-Positions.
Fuck. Der Kommissar
Bert hat mich gekillt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Max, Max, Max.
Pog ist... Oh, mein Team
ist Six-Header. Alter, guckt es euch an.
Guckt... Oh, ne. Jetzt sind sie alle down. Shit.
Ich hätte
releasen sollen.
Stört euch nicht daran, dass ich releasen sage.
Das ist... Das habe ich mich so angewöhnt
durch MMOs.
Oder durch ein MMO.
Für mich gibt es keinen Respawn. Für mich gibt es nur releasen.
Oh!
Achtung.
High-IQ-Play.
Naja. Hätte
funktionieren können. Hat er mich gearm-
Ne, er hat mich nicht gearmbrustet.
Hier gibt es ein richtig geiles
Play, was man machen kann. Mal gucken,
ob ich, ob
ich dazu komme.
Oh, ne. Die legen schon.
Shit.
Ich habe es gerade schon Legehände machen hören.
So.
Aber anscheinend haben wir es nochmal.
Ne, ich glaube, da komme ich nicht zu. Aber es gibt hier
was wirklich Praktisches. Vielleicht auf
A drüben mal gucken.
Ja, ist wirklich cool.
Was man nur als McKay, also nur
als Enterhaken-Dude machen kann.
Killer-Elite am Start.
So, hier kann man
durchflanken als Attacker.
Ah, haha.
Nicht gesehen.
Wallhack.
Wo sind denn die überhaupt gerade?
Ah, an B. Okay.
Ja, ist klar.
Oh, oh.
Ah, shit. Ja, da fliegen sie.
Da
fliegen sie. Und ist da gerade einer gespawnt
noch bei uns, während wir verreckt sind?
Leute, kaum sind wir verreckt,
schon liegt, liegt die Legehände an B.
Ne, an A.
Aber A ist auch schwierig. Also A ist tatsächlich
B, B ist, finde ich,
persönlich relativ easy zu verteidigen.
Ja, please,
sterben. Danke.
Next.
Ich dachte, da ist was in der Ecke.
Achtung, Yolo Res.
Mich trifft keiner.
Was?
So, jetzt ist an B angesagt. Oder?
Oh.
Ich habe hier ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, teilweise den
Fluss zu checken.
Spiel M, 5A3 oder
was anderes macht keinen Sinn zurzeit. Doch.
Ja, das Ding
streut, aber ich finde die
eigentlich ganz nice, weil die so eine hohe Schussrate hat.
Jetzt auf die Range, sagt's.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Wir müssen mal gucken, dass sie das nicht
umlaufen.
Ich meine, es ist eh schon relativ easy. Wir müssen
uns jetzt endlich noch leichter machen mit den OPsten
Waffen der OP-Waffen.
Ich glaube, wir haben fast alle Runden gewonnen heute.
Enemy spotted.
So, mal.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Vielleicht können wir jetzt...
Alter,
Mann.
Lohnt es sich Battlefield 2042 zu holen?
Nein.
Nicht zum Vollpreis.
Das einzige, was sich vielleicht lohnt, ist, wenn du es irgendwie für 15
Euro oder so kriegst. Ein paar Runden macht
das durchaus Bock. Gerade Rush ist sehr nice.
Moment, da ist was
geflankt. Achtung,
Achtung, Achtung. Achtung.
Fuck.
Von wo? Ah, der hat
mich gesehen. Shit. Weil das ist eigentlich der Play,
den ich euch zeige... Doch, alleine macht's
das auch halbwegs Bock. Den ich euch zeigen wollte.
Da oben drauf, Leute. Ihr könnt Kills
farmen ohne Ende.
Normalerweise.
Auf diesen da. Ist doch...
Alter, mein PP-Aim, Alter.
Ist ja nicht mal feierlich.
Guckt euch das an.
Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf.
Oh, shit.
Was da los ist.
Also, alleine finde ich, macht das Game auch
nah geil.
Macht das Game halbwegs Bock.
Aber im Team ist es natürlich
schon besser.
Moment, sind die Dinger immer noch auf dem Dach?
Die letzten zwei M-Comps?
Die haben nicht
wirklich diese kack M-Com
Pose immer noch ein Jahr
nach Release, oder?
Ach, man kann
da jetzt nicht mehr rüber.
Das ist natürlich okay.
Da muss man...
Oder kann man jetzt doch wieder rüber?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Guckt's euch an.
Bisschen hin und her fahren.
Äh, nope.
So war das nicht geplant.
Darf man hier stehen?
Nee.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Wir räumen von unten auf.
Ja, gut.
Hat das hier noch irgendeine Tür?
Ich seh nix mehr.
Nein!
Drecksacke.
Ah, shit.
Wie? Moment, die sind auf dem Dach?
Wir sind nicht aufs
Dach gekommen wieder.
Keck, keck, wait. Alle hier unten ist alles voll.
Shit.
Okay. Ich glaube,
das hab ich noch nie gesehen,
dass das hier jemand gewonnen hat.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Imagine Wagons.
Ah, wir hätten in den Heli reingemusst.
Da hast du recht, könnte man Map Selection machen.
Aber generell Map Selection,
Server Browser, sowas ist out.
Guck's dir an, in diesem Game nicht dabei.
MW2 nicht dabei.
Es gibt kaum noch Games,
wo das wirklich
wo das wirklich der Fall ist.
Wo ist er hin?
Wie kommt man da jetzt ruf?
Killer Elite.
Okay, da ist einer auf dem Dach.
Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt gewinnen wir.
Easy.
Ist unser Heli da oben?
Was ist denn das?
Ah.
Hä?
Das ist wirklich
ein mega sinnloses Feature.
Au. Alter.
Heil dich doch mal.
Ich hab fünf mal auf diesen komischen Heel gedrückt.
Nope. Gibt's nicht.
Chat, was ist besser?
Medipack oder Medipen?
Bei Medikit ist halt das Problem,
das hat längeren Reuse, finde ich.
Also hat's definitiv.
Nicht nur finde ich, hat auf jeden Fall.
Kann man da durch.
Höheren Reuse.
Aber dafür bricht das
Shit. Dafür bricht das nicht ab.
Ganz schön viel wieder hier oben los.
Leute, ihr habt die Poggers Position.
Direkt am M-Com campen, so müssen wir's machen.
So und nicht anders.
Wow.
Oh, oh, oh, lass mich in Ruhe.
Gegner, Gegner.
Also hier geht's grad richtig zur Sache.
Hier ist mir grad sogar ein bisschen viel Action,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Alter, heil dich doch mal
mit diesem komischen Medipin.
Oh, oh.
Shit. Fuck.
Das wär's Play gewesen.
Ich hätt ihn gekillt, er hat kaum noch
Leben gehabt, hätt ich defused. Ist nur einer.
Okay, ist down, ihr könnt defusen. Easy.
Defused, Leute. Defused, defused, defused.
Defused Champ.
Puh. Das war close.
Das war close.
Wo kommen die überhaupt
hierher? Sind hier Fahrstühle?
Ich kenn die Map über...
Sind hier Fahrstühle, wo die hochkommen?
Hier oder so?
Anscheinend.
Easy.
Aber die MCOMs, im Ernst, die sind wirklich nicht gut.
Meine Settings, ich hab alles auf Low,
bis auf
Texturen und...
Boah, frag nicht.
Ich zeig's dir gleich.
Ich hab aber auch nur 1080 TI.
Deswegen, und mir sind FPS lieber.
Als ein bisschen Optik.
Muss aber sagen, das Game sieht auch nicht
wahnsinnig geil aus in voller Optik.
Also in vollen Details.
Das ist eigentlich nie
eine Augenweide.
Wie sie es geschafft haben,
dass 2042 so nach Plastik aussieht,
wohingegen
Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5
richtig hübsch waren.
Und auch richtig coole Details hatten
von Fußspuren im Schnee
und Schlamm im Schnee.
Tja, aber nope.
Gibt's nicht.
Können die
Hovercraft-Dinger immer noch die Wände hochfahren?
Meines Wissens nach nicht.
Meines Wissens nicht.
Ich glaub, das können die schon ganz lange nicht mehr.
Weil ich das eigentlich cool fand.
So, pass auf, Leute.
Jetzt Kaleidoskop-Win.
Ich hab glaub ich noch nie
einen Kaleidoskop-Rush-Win gesehen.
Also einen Attacker-Win.
Also mal ganz kurz,
ich zeig dir mal schnell die Settings.
Ah ja, was war's denn jetzt eigentlich?
Medipack?
Medipack oder Medipen?
Weil Medipack hat auch den Vorteil,
das heilt andere...
Options.
Das ist so ein verkacktes Menü.
Also guck, ich hab alles auf Low.
Ne, ich hab hier.
Ich hab Texture-Kram auf Medium,
Rest alles auf Low, Low, Low.
Und das einzige, was ich hier hab, ist auf Ultra.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Was macht das überhaupt?
High-Fidelity-Objects-Amount.
Okay.
Ist die Map neu? Ja, Kaleidoskop ist neu.
Es gibt zwei neue Maps, Kaleidoskop und Renewal.
Ich mein, man kann nicht erwarten,
dass fast ein Jahr nach Release
ordentlich überarbeitet sind.
Da müssten sich ja mehr als zwei
Mapper in ihrer Freizeit drum kümmern.
Das Medipack
heilt... das heilt instant,
sobald du reingehst, ja?
Dafür hast du halt Reuse-Time von...
Weiß nicht, 10 Sekunden, 15 Sekunden
oder so?
Hat die Map Container? Rate mal.
Mr. Moogame, rate mal.
Hat sie
oder hat sie nicht?
Kommst du nicht drauf.
Da sind mindestens fünf Copernetis-Cluster
voll hier an Containern.
Und das ist noch nicht mal die containerlastigste Container-Map.
Ich glaube, die Map
mit den meisten Containern ist tatsächlich
die allerneueste.
Hat ein Flugzeug Flügel?
Ja, ist nur die Frage. Ein oder zwei?
Gibt ja auch welche mit einem.
Ist die Lobby wieder verbuggt?
Ich bin noch Level 69.
Ja, das kann man...
Also die Technologie ist eindeutig
noch nicht da, um
in der Lobby on the fly zu updaten.
Ich mein, so ne Karte replacen
zwischen zwei Runden.
Was heißt so ne Karte replacen?
Du musst das Overlay, das Zahl-Overlay
anpassen. Ok, Leute, ich glaube,
ich muss in die Lobby zurück,
weil es ist proggen.
Und dann join ich das Game und ihr solltet
ja mitkommen. Wollen wir nicht noch
nen Trailer schauen? Doch, machen wir.
Jetzt wird erstmal Battlefield weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier? Braucht kein Mensch.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Brauch ich alles nicht.
Next.
Rush.
Seid ihr noch in der Lobby?
Ach, jetzt seid ihr nicht mehr in der Lobby, oder wie?
Oder doch?
Ich check's nicht.
Ich such jetzt ein neues Game und invite euch wieder.
Das ist...
Das Menü
ist wirklich hart verkackt.
Kaleidoskop? Keckel?
Moment, da kommen wir doch gerade her.
Ja.
Das ist bestimmt wieder die kaputtende Map.
Jetzt sind wir wieder in der Lobby.
Oder nochmal Defense.
Wobei, nochmal Defense gibt
Schlimmeres. Zumindest haben sie es
gefixt. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, am Anfang
als Rush neu war, wo du immer nur
die gleiche Seite gespielt hast, wo es nie
zwischen Attacker und Defender gewechselt hat?
Das war richtig hängengeblieben.
Wo man sich so gedacht hat, Alter, ihr kriegt nicht mal
die Basics der Basics hin.
Oh ne, wir sind Attacker... Ne.
Ne, wir sind...
Wir sind
Defender.
Komm, wir spielen mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Komm, wir spielen mal wieder ein bisschen SMG.
Oder Noobtube.
Ich will den
Noobtube nicht anlocken. Hab da keinen Nerv
drauf.
Oh. Moment, das ist schon zweite
Base.
Nicer Spawn.
MonkaW.
Ok, B ist noch am Start.
Dann machen wir jetzt nicer plays an B.
A ist eh lost.
Oh shit.
Ok. Fuck, Alter.
Alter, wie viele sind denn
da bitte? Jawoll.
Fatal. GachiBuzz.
Diffuse lieber,
anstatt mich zu razen, Mann.
Disarm Champ.
Brake. Brake, Chat. Brake.
Nice.
Ok, das war close.
Das war close. Close as fuck, Mann.
So, Motion Sensor.
Ah, shit.
Den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Lafeu... Oh, ne.
Das ist irgendeine Franzose.
Kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Kein normaler Mensch kann das aussprechen.
Oh, Fatal, Pog. Ah, shit.
Respawn.
Max, vielleicht können wir
bei dir respawnen. Die sind da noch drin.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Fatal, ich hol dich schnell.
Pass auf, Pog. Pog, Pog, Pog.
Wie, der stirbt nicht?
Keck, wait.
Ah, shit.
Jetzt ist zu viel. Jetzt zu viel auf einmal.
Er wieder.
Ne, ne, ne. Das ist verloren.
Keine Chance. Da kommst du nimmer rein.
Wir haben alles probiert.
Was ist denn hier?
Guck dir das mal an.
Was ist denn hier los?
Leben am Limit, Leute.
Leben am Limit.
Das war knapp.
Ah.
Ich dachte, vielleicht kriegen wir noch irgendeinen.
Die Runde kriegen wir
aber massivst auf den Sack.
Alter, die rushen ja durch wie sonst was.
Ja, ja.
Du hast mich gesehen. Der denkt jetzt, ich komm da.
Aber ich komm nicht da. Ich komm da.
Grip.
Chet, lebt ihr noch?
Detke.
So, einfach A halten. Easy.
A halten und freuen und gewinnen.
Ich blick nicht durch,
wo ihr die ganzen farscht. Ach, da.
Ah, B. B wird eh nix.
Oh, da vorne.
Nein, nicht in S.
Alter, lass mein Bobbes in Ruhe.
Ich will nicht von hinten
gebankt werden.
Hat er mich voll weggesägt von hinten.
Der Sack.
Gachi Bass.
Egal, ob wir Bravo gelostet haben.
A ist das
Entscheidende.
Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Die Fuske.
Easy.
Oh.
Alter.
Der steht da einfach rum.
Kriegt natürlich auch noch was raus.
So, jetzt muss ich auch echt mal gucken.
Es ist keiner auf dem Dach. Okay.
Das ist Lost.
Es sei denn,
die kommen nochmal ran.
Lostge.
Ich hab noch nie nen Attacker-Win gesehen, Leute,
auf der Map.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht.
Ich hab ohne Scheiß noch nie
einen Attacker-Win auf der Map.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
die haben uns richtig weggeknallt.
Oh, Soundbug.
La...
Fausche.
Guck mal, wie kaputt das ist.
Es kommt immer
der gleiche Sound.
Das ist schwarz-weiß.
Guck mal, wie Boris lacht.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Container-Field.
Hört der Sound jetzt gar nicht mehr auf?
Ernsthaft?
Leute, jetzt haben wir den gleichen
Sound im Menü.
Vom Ende der Runde.
Nein, alles schon, alles gefixt.
Was haben wir unlockt?
Man weiß es nicht.
Oh, guck mal, ich hab ne neue Pistole unlockt.
Ist das ne...
Ist das ne Shotgun-Pistole?
Jetzt.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir Attacker
und jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich
richtig massivst auf den Sack.
Das Gegnerteam war so viel besser.
15 von 23.
P90.
Die müsste man auch mal
ausprobieren, ja?
Auf Game.
Los.
Serious Max, bist du rausgeflogen oder ist...
Bug.
Ich entwalte dich.
Bald die Runde geladen ist.
Social...
Wo ist er?
Der Opa Peitscher.
Der nicht.
Attackge...
Probieren wir mal das da aus.
Hm.
Mal gucken.
Mal schauen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, auf manchen Maps ist man als Attacker
schneller da als die Defender an der ersten Base.
Kann das sein?
Geht der in Wald wieder nicht?
Okay, das war PP-Gard hoch 10.
Dankeschön.
Gut, dass ich Teammates hab,
die mich resen, wenn ich wieder nix treffe.
So, mal kurz Motion senden.
Unten steht einer, unten steht definitiv...
Auf, auf, auf, auf, schnell.
Nice.
What?
Please schießen?
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Oh, Reskill, jawoll.
Ohohoho.
Ist der in der Queue?
Ernsthaft?
Das Game ist teilweise ziemlich verbuggt.
Nur manchmal.
Also so zu 95% der Zeit.
Meine Güte.
Alter.
Hier ist ja mal...
Ich muss hier runter, Alter.
Meine Güte.
Hilfe.
Ist das SBMM?
Oder was ist hier los?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich gerade hab, Alter.
100 Milliarden, dankeschön.
Die fetzt sich aber auch hart, man.
Oh, die Diffusen, die Diffusen, die Diffusen.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Boah, das ist ja gerade echt anstrengend hier.
Oh, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rats.
Pass auf, da sind welche.
Nice.
Oder auch nicht.
Die Gegner sind schon ziemlich heftig drauf gerade.
Ich brauch das andere.
Ah, ich hab das Tromag bestimmt unlocked mittlerweile.
Fadele, ich hol dich.
Alter, von hinten wieder.
Meine Güte.
Okay.
Wo ist er?
Der VIN muss jetzt.
So, mal kurz den Motion Sensor rüber.
Mal gucken.
Oh, von...
F.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, das war schlecht.
Ich bin direkt vom Auto gespawnt.
Sehr gut gemacht, Max.
Perfekt.
Direkt vom Auto.
Null.
Keck W.
Wie läuft's?
Auch ziemlich gut eigentlich.
Kann man nix sagen.
By the way, das ist die überarbeitete Map.
Nur mal so. Wo muss ich denn überhaupt hin?
Scheiße, Mann.
Die Map ist zwar überarbeitet, aber es ist immer noch nix.
Scheiße, Mann. Die Map ist zwar überarbeitet, aber es ist immer noch nix.
Morgen, KS.
Alter.
Überarbeitet, schön und gut.
Was kostet das Game?
Das ist ne gute Frage.
Oh, yes, nice.
Spawn.
Oh, nee.
Lass mich rein.
Ähm, tja, ich glaub, das Game wird noch zum Neupreis verkauft, oder?
Tja, ich glaub, das Game wird noch zum Neupreis verkauft, oder?
Or not.
Früher hat man dazu Commander Krieger Aim gesagt.
Oh Gott, an jeder Ecke hinter jedem Busch, Mann.
60 Euro ist immer noch ganz schön heftig, ja.
Wo ist das Aimcom?
Fahren wir nicht falsch?
What the hell?
Die Fahrzeuge sind schon merkwürdig teilweise.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Ich musste mich mal kurz...
Die sind krass, die Gegner, Alter.
Du kommst hier keine zwei Meter weit.
Was können wir denn machen?
Wir haben ja auch kein Heli.
Heli wär jetzt ganz praktisch.
Einmal haben wir gelegt.
Wir haben noch sieben Tickets. Das wird nix, Leute.
Das wird nix.
Noch sieben Tickets.
Also entweder kommen wir jetzt durch, ohne zu sterben
und legen, was nicht so aussieht.
Noch fünf Tickets.
Da ist ein Auto. Ja, nice.
Oh, pock, pock, pock.
Lost.
Spiel lieber Genshin, aber ich war doch noch nie in einer Wüste.
Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
How you lost last plant?
Lass mich raten, er hat geplantet.
Und jetzt stinke ich.
Wir haben... Das ist ganz einfach, wie wir last plant gelostet haben.
an den Rand der Map gefahren, anstatt das M-Com zu
verteidigen.
Was? Warum? Man weiß es nicht genau.
So, was haben wir
wieder
gekriegt?
Okay, zeig mal her.
Mal gucken, vielleicht sollten wir das
mal ausrüsten.
Spiel lieber. Ah, übrigens,
ich hab noch nie Genshin gespielt, ne?
Also nicht, dass es jetzt vielleicht so gewirkt hätte,
als wüsste ich auch nur entfernt, wovon ich rede.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Das Einzige, woher
ich Genshin kenne, ist vom Fabian, als er das
am Anfang gestreamt hat, ein bisschen.
Äh, Weapons?
Warte mal, ne?
Wo sind wir?
Da sind wir.
Wie, das ist immer noch nicht unlockt?
Monkeys? Alter.
Auf 40 Kills?
Na gut. Wollen wir mal nicht so sein.
Äh.
Das sucht
gerade gar kein Game, oder?
Oh.
Hat sich so angehört.
Ja, ich gebe zu,
ich hab schon sehr überzeugend vorgetragen,
das Sponsoring, ja. Kann man schon mal denken,
ich bin der Genshin-Experte.
War ganz, äh,
wirklich, äh, no,
Kaleidoskop, come on.
Gibt's nichts anderes mehr?
Chat, ich zieh noch mal raus,
ich hab keinen Bock auf noch mal Kaleidoskop.
Ich such noch mal neu.
Ich mein, das Game hat zwar
nicht viele Maps,
Leafgame, das hat zwar nicht viele Maps,
aber mehr als eine hat's.
Und, und,
viermal hintereinander Kaleidoskop
hab ich auch keinen Bock.
Auch wenn's ne überarbeitete Map ist.
Wir könnten Rushmaster
spielen, oder wie das hieß.
Dann kriegen wir wenigstens
zwei neue Maps.
Ja, komm, wisst ihr was?
Kennste?
Master of Arms Rush. Dann kriegen wir definitiv
Renewal oder Stranded.
Haben wir beides heute kaum gespielt.
Renewal noch gar nicht und Stranded, glaube ich, nur einmal.
Gibt nur
einen Server mit genug Spielern, ja.
Klingt jetzt blöd, wird aber wahrscheinlich
so sein in dem Spiel.
Wie viel...
Wartet mal, gerade während das lädt.
Äh, wie sieht's denn gerade aus? Spielerzahlen?
Ach, für Battlefield
2042-Verhältnisse echt,
echt okay.
Kann man nix sagen.
Zehntausend Spieler?
Das ist das Doppelte bis Dreifache,
was es relativ lange hatte.
Okay, auf geht's.
Gerade Runden anfangen. Defense.
Da könnten wir ein bisschen spät sein.
Die sind schon mit dem LLV direkt an dem...
Meistens gehen die Gegner
zuerst auf A,
aber das ist immer so ein bisschen random.
Also Leute, übrigens auch überarbeitete Map.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich muss da oben drauf.
Ha! Leute,
defused, defused
und gekillt dabei.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
Das erste, was man sieht,
rote Container, passt mal auf.
Renewal wird die Container-Fans, wird euch begeistern.
Die haben nicht nur rote Container,
die haben grüne Container, die haben sogar...
Ihr seht's noch nicht richtig, doch,
da ist es ein bisschen... Die haben sogar blaue Container.
Überlegt euch mal.
Get, gettet das mal, ja?
Dreifarbige Container.
Massivster Pog.
Shit.
Oh, C5.
Schon geil, ja.
Schon geil.
Und ich glaube, die haben sogar...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es könnte sein, es könnte sogar sein,
dass die sogar noch braune Container haben.
Schrei nicht so rum, Mensch.
Okay, okay, B.
B.
Äh, was? Moment.
Lebt doch.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Ah, der hat Amor gehabt.
Shit.
Okay.
Ja.
Übrigens, kein Fallschaden,
wenn man nach unten...
Gravitation ist nicht existent für Battlefield.
Braucht man nicht.
Overrated.
Erdanziehung, wer braucht sowas schon?
Aber ganz ehrlich,
das ist das kleinste Problem, was das Game hat.
Gravitation outdated,
overrated, she baited.
Da läuft was.
Was ist da? Guck mal da.
Keine Chance.
Nice, nur noch 34 Tickets. Easy.
Normalerweise wird die erste Base übelst schnell überrannt.
Kurz andere Seite checken,
ob da noch was ist.
Da ist was.
Ich seh nix, weil...
Oh, fett. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich dachte, da ist was.
Okay, jetzt hab ich ein Problem.
Achtung.
Ui.
Ah, ja, ja.
Nix gemacht, die Runde, außer von A nach B gerannt.
Aber es hat funktioniert.
Okay. Easy.
Boah, wie das Ding nach oben zieht.
Trotz Tabs.
Darf ich auch mal rein?
Ich hab noch nie geschossen mit dem Ding.
Ich warte jetzt, bis der weggeht.
Und dann geh ich auch mal rein.
Ich glaub, der geht nicht weg.
Ich glaub, der bleibt bis zum bitteren Ende
jetzt in seiner komischen
Gatling-Gun hocken.
Lone Reserved Roops.
Okay, die haben's aufgegeben.
Kommt nix mehr durch.
Leute, ähm, spiele einer von euch Dota 2?
Keine Sorge, ich will weder mit euch spielen, noch fange ich hier an, Dota zu streamen oder so.
Interessiert mich nur.
Ne?
Ich guck in letzter Zeit
extrem gerne Dota-Streams.
Ich find das mega
spannend und entspannend zeitgleich.
3500 Stunden.
Okay, das heißt, du bist Einsteiger jetzt.
Du hast quasi Einsteiger geschafft mit 3000 Stunden.
Das Spiel ist ja übelst kompliziert, Alter.
Ich mein, ich spiel ja gar nicht, ich bin reiner Zuschauer.
Das heißt, ich checke noch weniger.
Oh, oh, oh.
Aber,
das ist wirklich
Sixhead.
Aber ich guck, ich guck mega gerne Dota und
Ich find's auch spannend, spannend und entspannend gleichzeitig.
Warum nicht LOL? Weiß nicht.
LOL gefällt mir nicht zu gucken.
Also, ich spiele weder LOL noch Dota, aber
ähm.
Also, ich hab das Einser-Dota,
den Warcraft, das ist ja kein Mod.
Das ist eine Custom-Map gewesen.
Davon gab's ja auch mehrere
in dieser Richtung.
Ähm, bisschen gespielt, aber
das ist nicht der Rede wert, ja.
Du guckst voll gerne World of Tanks, aber zockst das.
Ach, World of Tanks, Leute!
Fällt mir noch ein, da muss ich mal kurz
in meine E-Mail gucken. Ich hab ein
Sponsoring-Angebot von World of Tanks
bekommen.
Und wenn ich das so ähnlich machen kann wie Genshin,
dann ist es kein Ding.
Denn da erzähle ich euch dann,
World of Tanks ist das Leading-Tank-blablabla-Game
und ihr könnt jetzt den neuen Tank ausprobieren,
wenn ihr den QR-Code in meiner Beschreibung scannt.
Haha, ich war noch nie in einem Tank und ich freu mich so sehr,
dass ich einen Tank fahren darf. Ladet euch jetzt!
Dann mach ich da wieder nen krassen Sellout.
Auf geht's.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Ich muss mich so wegpüssen, Leute.
Man hört's, glaub ich, im Video, ja.
Genshin, jetzt mal ohne Mist.
Ich glaube,
von diesen ganzen Free-to-Play-Games
ist Genshin immer noch das Beste,
wo man zumindest die ersten, frag mich nicht,
50 Stunden oder so spielen kann,
ohne richtig krass rein zu cashen.
Und, und,
eins muss man sagen,
Genshin ist voll das Frauenspiel.
Also, wer mit
Mädels was zum Reden haben will, muss
Genshin Impact spielen.
Und, hast du schon,
wie heißt der neue, ich hab's vorgelesen,
wie heißen die neuen Helden?
Lilou?
Nilou?
Ich hab's vergessen, keine Ahnung.
Ich werd's auch nicht spielen.
Du kennst nur Cringe Weebs, die da spielen.
Es sind nicht,
es sind nicht nur Cringe Weebs.
Kann ich dir, kann ich dir sagen.
Ein Kollege auf der Arbeit hat seine Freundin
über Genshin kennengelernt. Siehste?
Also ich weiß, dass das komplette
Female Valorant Team von nem,
äh,
den Namen will ich euch nicht sagen, also von,
von jemand, den ich kenne,
der coacht das und der meint,
die spielen alle Valorant.
Äh, die spielen alle Genshin, anstatt
Valorant. Aber Female
Team. Manchmal, manchmal
frage ich mich immer so, also ich bin
voll dafür, dass es Female Teams gibt,
muss man ja Disclaimer dazu sagen, sonst
beschwert sich da wer.
Leute,
ähm, bei manchen Orgas
hab ich den Eindruck, die haben die Female Teams
einzig und allein als Werbe, ähm,
Placement. Und nicht
so sehr für tatsächlich, äh,
Turniere spielen. Okay, hier
rast mich keiner. Oh, Alter,
die sind schon an A dran? The fuck?
Ich hab drei gekillt auf dem Weg zu A, wie können
die schon an A dran sein?
Die Weeps wieder hier.
Fragt mich nicht, was das mit Weeps
zu tun hat. Wahr-wahrscheinlich
weil Genshin
hat mit Weeps überhaupt nichts zu tun. Wo ist
den Baro eigentlich, wenn man ihn braucht?
Damit wenigstens einer weiß von,
bei dem Thema Bescheid.
Okay, das war Pepega-Style.
Pepega, Pepega-Aim.
Richtig krass wieder.
Alter, Max, du musst dich mal länger als
zwei Stunden konzentrieren können aufs Game.
Das geht mit 38 auch.
Stell dich mal net so an,
Alter, kack nur.
Ich merk das, wenn ich länger als zwei Stunden
oder als eineinhalb Stunden gespielt hab,
ich spiel, ich fang an, mega hirnlos zu
spielen. Ich renn rein, ohne zu gucken
und geb mir überhaupt nicht mehr Mühe beim Zielen.
Einfach, äh. Huch, wo sind wir denn hier?
Alter, das ist mitten im Gegnerspawn.
Kann ich nicht pressen,
sorry.
Okay, die sterben nicht, nice.
GG Eats. Oh, oh, oh, oh, der pusht.
C4.
Äh, den hab ich net gesehen.
Oh, danke,
danke. Oh, oh, oh, oh, Pog, Pog, Pog.
RIP. Aber das ist gut,
solange die uns hier am Spawnrape hindern,
umso weniger
können sie reinpushen.
Eigentlich richtig Pogge.
Ach, shit, das wär so
ein cooler Flank gewesen.
Okay, Max.
Wieder konzentrieren.
Aufhören, hirnlos reinzurennen.
Fälschlich kann ich da
nicht pressen, du liegst in der Wand.
Okay.
Konzentraten.
Ha, der looted, der Typ im Spawn.
Keck.
Wo sind die Subs der IQ singt?
Ich glaub, wir hatten doch schon 15 Subs oder so.
Sieht schon taktischer aus, ja.
Ja, ich,
das ist wirklich so.
Nach 1,5 Stunden, also ich schalt voll das Gehen ab.
Früher konnt ich 8 Stunden durchspielen,
konzentriert am Stück.
Das geht nicht mehr.
Wenn ich 1,5 Stunden gespielt hab, ich
und ich mich nicht selbst zusammenreiße,
pipega ich nur noch rum.
Oder treff nix, aber gut,
das mach ich auch so nicht.
Guck schon wieder. Normalerweise wär ich da nie rausgerannt.
Richtig, richtig hängengeblieben.
Oh, oh, oh, was macht denn der Typ da oben?
Der aimt doch hier ab.
Hat er gerätzt?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Ach, Mensch.
Das Ding ist, guck mal, wenn ich die SMG auf Range kill.
Rentner halt, ist echt so.
Wirklich.
Rentner-Extrem.
Boomer.
Richtig, richtig Boomer-Time.
Schon spät, Leute.
Schon spät.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie ganz schön von der Seite ran, gepusht.
Guck mal, fast verreckt, obwohl ich den 3 Sekunden vorher gesehen hab.
Links, links ist wieder einer.
Moment, sind die schon drinnen?
Oder ist er auf dem Dach?
Okay, 10 Tickets noch.
Easy Win, Leute, Easy Win.
Wisst ihr, wie cool es wär,
wenn mal Leute spotten könnten in dem Spiel?
Dann würdste auch was sehen.
Shit.
Siehste, total dumm, da runter zu laufen.
Nee, Vollpreis würde ich auf gar keinen Fall kaufen.
Oh oh, ganz schön blöde von mir.
Nice.
GG.
Am 20 geht's abwärts, Leute.
Wie stehst du eigentlich zu Valorant?
Ich spiele kein Valorant.
Ich gucke kein Valorant Rule 34.
Ich schau kein Valorant E-Sport.
Und ich interessier mich, ehrlich gesagt, auch nicht groß für Valorant.
Hat sich das Spiel verbessert?
Ja, es gibt jetzt Rush und ein gescheites Hauptmenü.
Viele Bugs sind aber immer noch da.
Vorhin beispielsweise wieder verbuggte Lobby gehabt
vor nem Spiel, was nicht aufhört.
Zigmal, dass Leute nicht nachjoinen können
und sonst was.
Ist halt...
Es ist halt immer noch ziemlich kaputt
und das Ganze irgendwie neun...
Vor Release.
Ist ja schon ganz schön lang her.
Wann kam das raus? November?
Anfang November?
Gar nicht.
Ende Oktober?
Wird geruscht.
Komm hier mal.
Wenigstens hab ich nach der Runde wahrscheinlich
das Magazin unlockt.
So, wir können jetzt auf A gehen,
aber wir machen hier die Six Head Action
und flanken mal durch auf B.
In der Hoffnung, dass uns keiner gesehen hat.
Was aber wahrscheinlich nicht...
Da doch schon Gegner am Start.
Darf ich doch mal was killen heute?
Heiß.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ganz schön viel los.
Aber die haben wir ganz schön überrannt jetzt, hä?
Leute.
Die haben wir ganz schön überrannt.
Oh, da kommt einiges jetzt hier.
Guckt euch meinen PP gar eh mal an. Wahnsinn.
Aufgehört zu konzentrieren.
Schon direkt am verkacken.
Da hab ich aber Glück gehabt,
dass die genauso PP-Guard haben wie ich.
Next.
Lasst mich in Ruhe. Weg da.
Muss jetzt
nice flank action machen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Kann ich nicht holen, wer auch immer.
Spawnen lieber bei mir rein.
Wenn ich zurück gehe an der Stelle,
der aimt immer noch ab.
Wenn ich im Schiff bin.
Easy.
Einmal weggeguckt.
Boah. Alter. Shotgun.
Ne, nicht Shotgun. Ähm.
Granat. Granat. Noobtub wieder.
Weg noobtubt.
Noobröhrt.
Noob. Mit der Noobröhre.
Noobtubt.
What the fuck?
Was zum? Was geht hier ab?
Hallo?
Aufstehen.
Brrrröüüüüüt.
Brrrröüüt.
Crepels out. Pass mal auf.
Jetzt.
Massive. Massive.
Hier, pass mal auf. Hier ist beste Posi.
Beste Posi auf der ganzen Map.
16 O Scope.
Nee, die ist nicht gestorben.
Ah, fuck.
Was ist denn
aktuell?
Was ist denn aktuell?
Noch ein gutes Assault Rifle.
Der Typ ist immer noch da, oder?
Was?
Direkt.
SCAR M4.
Du meinst die M16, oder?
Eine M4 gibt es glaube ich nicht.
M16.
One Man Army.
Ja, hätte ich sofort ausgerüstet.
Noobtube am Start.
Flank, Flank Action.
Komm mal, Leute.
Hier wieder.
Ganzen Kubernetes Cluster ausgeleert.
Stalker-Files am Start.
Nein!
Mensch.
Killen ist übrigens verboten gerade.
Ich darf nichts mehr töten.
Wir müssen nur gucken, dass da nichts von hinten kommt.
Okay, vielleicht kommt...
Oh, da ist ein Schneiber.
Schneiber-Dude.
Schneiber-Man.
Granate war doch gar nicht mehr da.
Da oben ist er.
Nee, nee.
Du redst mich bloß nicht.
Ich mach Docker-Compose-Refresh erstmal.
Der macht das gleiche wie ich.
Der gammelt da oben auf dem Schiff.
Okay, die erwisch ich.
Da oben.
Fuck, ich dachte, der umläuft mich.
Rekt.
Out.
Enter-Hakt.
Alter.
Wie viel ist da auf dem Schiff los, Mann?
Aber wir haben schon...
Easy.
Guck mal.
Während wir Schiff-Action machen.
Und gewinnen wir einfach die Runde.
E-S-I.
Easy.
So kann man's auch machen.
Alle auf dem Schiff verrückt machen.
Und unten werden die ganzen...
Legehennen die Eier legen.
Easy win.
Outstanding Performance.
Wir könnten mal LMG ausprobieren.
Ob's gescheite LMGs gibt.
Nee, vorher machen wir...
Äh, Trompeten.
Trommel-Magazin.
Porke.
So, wieder Zeugs unlocked, was mich nicht juckt.
Wieder Battle Pass Progression unlocked, die mich auch nicht juckt.
Wir können schnell den Trailer gucken.
Äh, Trailer von...
Ah, nee, das Game geht schon los, oder?
Nee.
Wie ist das denn?
The Finals.
So, das ist das Game...
Ach so, ihr seht gar nix, gell?
Ich hab ja nur...
Ach, Mist.
Ich hab ja Ingame Capture an.
Richtig, richtig blöde.
Ich hab immer noch kein Trommel-Magazin.
Ich hab immer noch kein Trommel-Magazin freigeschaltet.
Na toll.
Das einzig gute MLG ist die Avant...
Was?
Avant...
Avanti.
Also, sprich...
Packen wir das doch mal.
Äh...
Das da?
Das muss man dafür machen, zum Unlocken.
34.
34 was?
Ach, Battle Pass Tier 34.
Ah, äh...
Und wo sind wir?
Ah.
Und...
Oh.
Will ich das wirklich...
Was kosten das?
Kackel.
Ich geb dafür doch kein Geld aus.
Wie viel Battle...
Wie viel Battlefield Points hab ich eigentlich?
Hab das...
Hat das irgendjemand gesehen gerade?
Oh, neue Map.
Was heißt neue Map?
Überarbeitete Map.
Gleich mal als Attacker?
Wär auf jeden Fall nice.
Mach die Weekly Challenge.
Ja, aber da muss ich Sachen machen, die ich nicht machen will.
Zum Beispiel Looptube-Kills und Melek-Kills...
...und so komisches Zeug.
Was?
No Pass.
Spiel ich lieber so, wie ich Bock hab.
Oh, wir sind mal tatsächlich Attacker.
Komm.
Gib ihm.
Attack-Saw.
Will ich mitfahren?
Hopp.
Jo.
Nehm ich mit.
Hopp.
Was sind das? Bots?
Ah, sind zwei Bots drinne.
Die müssten aber gleich geplacet werden.
Achso, ich bin Fahrer.
Guck mal, die haben ein Tablet mit dem Auto drauf.
War sich nicht bewegt.
Oh.
Hopp.
Haha.
Versuch das mal zu schaffen, das wird nix.
Outplayed by Bots.
Oh megalul.
Okay, nice.
Schön wieder rein spawnen.
Alter!
Wie...
Oh, jetzt...
Jetzt, Mensch.
Oh, da ist noch ein Gegner.
Okay.
Also.
Die haben mich gesehen.
Ah, wir müssen jetzt...
Wir müssen jetzt da durch.
Pass mal auf.
Okay.
Alter, das kannst du wirklich nicht Dauerfeuer machen.
Das ist...
Be-be-be-be-be-bega.
Okay, die Gegner sind einfach nur...
total...
total hirnlos, Alter.
LOL, sind die blöde.
Ich hab...
Leute.
Ich schwöre.
Ich hab gedrückt.
Das war nämlich Six Headplay.
Ich wollte von hinten
einfach reinflanken.
Nice, danke für das Movement Game.
Okay, er war zu langsam von mir.
Ja.
Ja, ich hätte das...
glaube ich halt einfach an andere Posi machen müssen.
Nee, Kollege.
So einfach mach ich's dir nicht.
Die retzen.
So.
Jetzt können wir langsam durchpushen, denk ich mal.
Von hinten reinflanken.
Ja.
So muss es sein.
Die reinschieben.
Äh.
Was?
Das war nicht in Range?
Habt ihr gesehen?
Ich hab den...
Ich hab den gesperrt mit meiner...
Äh.
Grappling Gun.
Okay.
Jetzt ist es natürlich schwierig hier rüber zu kommen.
Jetzt haben sie gute Posi's.
Smoke.
Wir brauchen Smoke.
Ganz wichtig.
Wir brauchen keine komische Dingsmine.
Wir brauchen ne...
keine EMP.
Was ist denn hier von Smoke?
Das da.
Oh, von hinten.
Ihr werdet Gachi bust, Leute.
Was ist denn das?
Okay.
Eingesmoked.
Fuck.
Okay.
Ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Ist der PC aktuell?
Nee.
Ich hab ne 1080 TI.
Das ist nicht aktuell.
Leute.
Das wird knapp.
Okay.
Mit der Muni über die Range wird das nix.
Aber danach Trommelmagazin.
Drei Stunden ohne Rage-Quit.
Es ist erstaunlich, gell?
Ja.
Der PC ist noch aktuell.
Also, wenn es der PC mit der 1080 TI ist,
ja, dann ist das noch aktuell.
Und man mag es...
Hallo?
Hallo.
Game.
Man mag es kaum glauben.
Der ist noch aktuell.
Es ist aber alles...
alles auf Low.
Achtung.
Den outplayen wir jetzt.
Der kommt hier runter.
Ich wusst's.
Die Weeps.
Hab ich bitte nicht.
Was ist mit Weeps zu tun?
Nix.
Die Weeper.
Leute, ich hör hier 50 Gegner laufen.
Aber es ist gar nix.
Okay.
PP-Guard.
Wann wird der erneuert?
Naja.
Planmäßig Ende des Jahres eigentlich.
Ich mein, das Ding ist jetzt 5 Jahre alt.
Aber...
Das hängt ein bisschen davon ab,
wie das mit den Nvidia-Grafikkarten wird.
Also...
Ich hab ausgerechnet, ich brauch ungefähr 4.500 Euro für einen neuen Rechner in der Kombi, die ich...
...die ich haben will.
Und ganz im Ernst.
Wenn der mal 1.000 Euro billiger wär, hätte ich auch kein Problem mit.
Die Grafikkarte ist halt einfach nur sau teuer.
Jeder will nicht sterben.
What?
Dankeschön.
So, jetzt.
Passt mal auf.
Das hier muss alles weg?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Passt mal auf.
Massive.
Massive Six Head.
Shit.
Ich will aufs Dach.
AMD kommt nicht in Frage.
Na, für die CPU.
CPU-technisch wird das wahrscheinlich in AMD.
Ah, what?
Alter, der hat aber schnell gewesen.
CPU-technisch wird's wahrscheinlich AMD.
GPU-technisch...
...eigentlich Nvidia geplant.
Fuck.
Alter, die wollten mich alle razzen.
Ich bin einfach nur...
Ich hab sie in den Tod gebetet.
You got gebeted.
Nee, AMD ist die Frage.
Na doch, AMD kommt auch in Frage.
Je nachdem, was die vorstellen, ja.
Mal schauen, was AMD für Grafikkarten vorstellen.
Mal schauen.
Mensch, die kommen jetzt nicht raus.
Ich will bloß nicht geflankt werden.
Oh, das ist eine Smoggy.
Ich hab gar keine...
Ich dachte, ich hab noch den Bewegungssensor dabei.
Nice.
Easy.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja, Smoggy ist gute Deckung.
Wenn man sie ordentlich wirft und nicht vor sich.
Hallo?
Danke.
Aufs Dach.
Äh...
Ja.
Unter mir.
Keck.
Ah, shit.
Das hat er gut gemacht.
Der wusste genau, wo ich stehe.
Er hat sich bewegt und ich bin nicht stehen geblieben.
Äh...
Umgedreht.
Er ist nicht stehen geblieben, er hat sich bewegt und ich bin stehen geblieben.
Das heißt, er wusste, wo ich war und ich...
...Shooter Basics nicht befolgt.
Also, Fade, ich würd dich razzen, wenn ich wüsste, von wo es hier gerade schießt.
Bin grad ein bisschen planlos.
Okay, B noch, dann haben wir's.
Wow.
MonkaS, Alter.
Könnt ihr mal aufhören, mich die ganze Zeit von hinten zu killen?
Alter, 26, 10, der Nächste hat 7.
Alter, wir haben richtig geownt.
Was ist da los?
Ohne das Team wär's wieder nicht möglich gewesen.
Massive, massive Team-Erfolg hier.
Auf, komm.
Springt mir doch mal einer.
Ich wollt grad sagen, springt mir doch mal mit bei einer ins Fadenkreuz.
Nice.
Also, wenn wir nicht Erster sind...
...Squad, weiß ich auch nicht.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Massive Squad-Effort.
Outstanding Performance.
Most Kills.
Leute, wir haben alle drei Karten am Ende.
Und Squad 1.
Ja, so ist gut.
Muss sein.
So mag ich das.
Ja, das versteh ich nicht.
Die hätten theoretisch einfach nur den M-Com Sound kopieren müssen.
Den neuen M-Com Sound mag ich auch nicht.
Giga-Chat-Matic.
Ja.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was AMD zeigt an Grafikkarten.
Wann ist denn das?
Wann wird denn das vorgestellt?
Oder wurde das schon vorgestellt?
Also, die neuen Ryzen-CPUs sind schon da.
Also, vorgestellt, noch nicht erschienen.
Wobei.
4. Oktober?
1. Oktober?
Die kommen doch jetzt irgendwie raus, oder?
Die Ryzen.
Dinger.
So Leute, wir müssen mal ein bisschen was anderes spielen.
So eine Runde SMG.
Kein Bock.
Immer.
Wobei, hab ich jetzt eigentlich das Magazin freigespielt?
Ja.
Ist schon was irgendwas?
Hab ich jetzt gar nicht gespielt?
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht gecheckt?
Wie viel hatte ich?
26 Kills!
Da müsste ich jetzt eigentlich das Trommel-Magazin haben.
Weapons.
Nice.
Yo!
Ja!
Ja.
Sehr schön.
Dann können wir jetzt ein bisschen länger Ppega aimen, bis uns die Puste ausgeht.
Wisst ihr, ich bin immer noch begeistert.
5 Jahre alt ist der Rechtex erhalten.
den ich da bestellt hab, gell? Und
ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, das ist für mich
als quasi so Generation
der Leute, die sich alle eineinhalb
Jahre früher neue Rechner kaufen müssen, komplett
unverständlich,
dass das überhaupt möglich ist.
Das ist ein Bot.
Kekwait, das ist ein Bot.
Oh man, die Hälfte
besteht wieder aus Bots, Alter.
Es dauert jetzt wieder drei
Minuten, bis er aufgefüllt ist.
Was hat sich Dice nur mit dieser
Bot-Kacke gedacht?
Ernsthaft, was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Crap, Mann?
Guckt euch das an.
Als wäre das wirklich eine gute
Idee gewesen, da Bots
einzufügen.
Besser als Solo in der Lobby? Nö.
Das Spiel sollte einfach nicht starten.
Das Spiel sollte bei 80% Spieler starten
und
nicht starten,
nur weil es mit Bots aufgefüllt ist.
Ja, das ist halt dumm,
dass überhaupt Bots drinnen sind.
Guckt euch das
an.
Kek.
Kein Witz los.
L.Potter spielt bei den Gegnern mit.
Casuals müssen auch was treffen.
Das Game ist so easy, Leute.
Ich bin der größte Boomer
und bashe eigentlich
den Größteil der Runden, ja.
Das sollte alles sagen.
Gut, ich meine, ich bin Boomer mit ziemlich viel Battlefield.
Stunden insgesamt.
Aber trotzdem,
das Game ist easy.
Also wenn sich da einer beschwert,
dass er nichts auf die Reihe kriegt,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist eigentlich kein Ding.
So, ah, guck mal.
Jetzt ist das Game voll.
Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt können wir uns wieder anstrengen.
Gravitation.
Overrated.
Outdated.
Chebated.
Rekt.
Gucken, ob die über die andere Seite flanken.
Ich meine, die wären clever,
wenn sie noch über die andere Seite gehen würden,
obwohl das M-Com schon weg ist.
Aber so clever sind sie anscheinend nicht.
Die gehen straight auf A.
Wachs, vielleicht.
Rock.
So, mal wieder meine Lieblingsecke auf der Map.
In der Hoffnung, mich trifft das Auto nicht.
Beste Ecke.
Dich kann kaum was killen.
Und du kannst alles sehen.
Okay, Gegner sind alle aufgefüllt.
Oh, oh.
Das ist jetzt schwierig,
wenn der Typ da oben steht.
Das Ding ist auf Range so rotzig.
Geht, drüben ist nichts mehr.
Dachte eigentlich,
da sind ein paar rübergegangen.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Mein Team hat das easy im Griff.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die kommen überhaupt nicht ran.
Doch, da ist doch einer.
Sag ich doch.
Nein.
Mit dem letzten Leben.
Aber es ist ein Medic neben mir.
Vielleicht retzt er mich.
Oh.
High IQ Spieler.
Guck mal, wie manchmal der Mini-Panic geht.
Bombi.
Alter.
Wie?
Der fliegt durch den Kopf durch, oder?
Nice.
Nein.
Die lege Henne ist da.
Die haben nur noch 30 Tickets.
Jetzt haben wir wieder nicht aufgepasst.
Richtig, richtig,
Ausrufezeichen PP geeint.
Richtig dumm.
Ich dachte mir, easy win, easy win.
Es ist wieder rumgehampelt.
Und dann zack, nix.
Ah, siehste.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt nächste Base anstrengen.
Richtig verkackt wieder.
Das kriegen wir nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist, ich glaube, das ist dead.
Ja.
Boom.
Big Shuck.
Ja, Chat, ihr habt recht.
Ihr habt recht.
Oh, Tainzer.
Pog, dankeschön.
Zehn Abos.
Massive Subscriptions hier.
Dankeschön, dankeschön.
Wir hatten was gekriegt hier.
Das Plicksauverlord.
Obmus aus Leko.
Ja, der ist oft da.
Der hat's verdient.
Captain Chuffi, Semmel, Rageman, Zoronata, Katsor, Katots und Filu.
Hold the line.
Let's get going.
Ah, ja, ja.
Alter.
Die Schleimadudes, Mann.
Ach, das war gar nicht der, oder was?
Okay, schnell wieder rein.
Als Defender ist Sterben nicht schlimm.
Okay, ich hätte eigentlich wetten können, da ist was.
Naja, so nicht.
Oh, die haben geplantet.
Oh, oh.
Hätte ich mich angestrengt und den auf Kopf gezielt, wäre er weg gewesen.
Also, bei mehr als 100 FPS kann man noch die Grafik hinstellen.
Naja, nee.
Nee, kann man nicht.
Erstens willst du ja das möglichst, äh, aus, also willst du ja auch keine Drops drin haben.
Und das Game fühlt sich mit 100 FPS bei weitem nicht so flüssig an, wie es andere Games mit 100 FPS anfühlen.
Shit.
Ähm, dazu kommt, mehr FPS immer gut.
Selbst, selbst 150, 200, immer mehr FPS besser.
Und du hast noch das weitere Problem.
Das Spiel sieht nicht sonderlich bedeutend viel besser aus.
Kommt ihr noch dabei?
Äh, ja.
Es lohnt sich.
Alter, es lohnt sich nicht.
Mauslag, ja, ich glaube, ist ganz gut.
Ich müsste mich erstmal wieder konzentrieren und ordentlich spielen.
Leute, nach drei Stunden.
Boomer war schon nach eineinhalb Stunden müde, aber jetzt ist vorbei.
Man's not hot.
What?
What the hell?
Regroup in this position.
Hostile charges disabled.
Code 1.
What?
Ich glaube, ich habe gegen die, gegen das stationäre Ding geballert.
Die letzte, okay, das ist vorletzte Base.
Das ist auch nicht letzte Base, vorletzte Base.
Okay, jetzt High IQ Plays rausholen, Leute.
High IQ Plays rausholen.
Wird, wird Zeit.
Ist jetzt, ist jetzt notwendig.
Oh, Location Revealed ist, glaube ich, schlecht.
Okay, Leute.
Könnt ihr vergessen.
Be ready.
Aber immerhin noch ein bisschen was gekillt.
Immerhin noch.
Äh, 1080p.
Battlefield 2042 E-Sports.
Oh, ja.
Battlefield E-Sport.
Gab's das jemals?
Gab es jemals wirklich Battlefield E-Sport?
Ich weiß, mein ehemalsiger Overwatch-Teamkollege hat BFBF4 Competitive gespielt, aber das hatte ja keine wirkliche...
Jetzt irgendwie große E-Sports-Szene.
Leute, hier gibt's tatsächlich mal einen Trick auf der Map, den ich ganz gut finde.
Man kann den Container aufmachen, sich da drin...
...verstecken.
Ey, er ist aber wirklich nicht schlecht, weil sonst hast du hier wenig Deckung, wird alles weggesprengt.
Sag mal.
Warte.
Haben die schon Legehände gemacht?
Passt es nicht.
Disarmed Champ.
Okay, A ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger einzunehmen.
In, in den Kopf.
Brage, Brage!
Fuck!
War knapp.
Chat, ihr habt nicht genug geprayed.
Ich hab nicht ein Brage-Emote gesehen.
Chat ist schuld.
Easy.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt ist Brage...
Jetzt ist Brage auch zu spät.
Pass auf, der fährt mich gleich um.
Da ist er doch.
Habt ihr doch hier einen gesehen gerade?
Hopp.
Also das hier kann man ganz gut defenden.
Wow!
Irgendwie hat mein Hirn nicht reagiert, dass es ein Gegner ist am Anfang.
So, hu.
Ich dachte, dass er hier einen haben würde.
Ich hab den hier nicht gesehen.
Ich dachte, das ist irgendein komisches Gadget auf der Wand.
Äh, komisches Gadget an der Wand.
Und dann war es ein Gegner.
Boomer-Hirn, unfähig.
Jetzt.
Oh, Scheiße.
Also Granatenradius abschätzen ist echt nicht so ohne.
Ich dachte, das ist weit an mir vorbei geflogen, das Ding.
Lul.
Das können wir halten.
Das könnten wir halten.
Das ist durchaus möglich.
Oh, Maxi, ich hol dich.
Ah, ne.
Gib das immer 50% Damage-Assist?
50 XP in Damage-Assist?
Unabhängig davon, ob man überhaupt, äh, wie viel Damage man überhaupt gemacht hat.
Scheint so.
Oh, nice, nice.
Leute, hier.
Smoke und jetzt wird gepusht.
Alter.
Immer im falschen Moment.
Die Runde geht gar nichts.
Aber ich merke, mein Boomer-Hirn macht es nicht mal lange mit, Leute.
Oh, nice, nice.
Leute, hier.
Smoke und jetzt wird gepusht.
Alter.
Immer im falschen Moment.
Die Runde geht gar nichts.
Aber ich merke, mein Boomer-Hirn macht es nicht mal lange mit, Leute.
Oh, nice, nice.
Leute, hier.
Smoke und jetzt wird gepusht.
Alter.
Immer im falschen Moment.
Die Runde geht gar nichts.
Aber ich merke, mein Boomer-Hirn macht es nicht mal lange mit, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich brauche ein bisschen irgendwas anderes.
Oh, oh.
Close, close, close.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ich treff nichts mehr.
Die Map sieht weitaus besser aus.
Ja.
Vor allem mehr Container.
Fuck, alle tot.
Shit.
Deutlich mehr Container.
Oh, nice.
Leute, hier.
Und Kisten und Absperrungshütchen.
Was du heute Abend essen sollst, Spaghetti.
Ah, Max, ich hätte dich geholt.
Ich bin gerade da.
Spaghetti, fuck.
Oh, da, Legehände, Legehände.
Was.
Lol.
Brake, Leute.
Brake, Brake, Brake, Brake, Brake, Brake.
Easy.
Diffuse.
Win.
Eine Runde spielen wir noch.
Wobei, abhängig von der Map.
Abhängig von der Map.
Also wenn jetzt Discarded oder irgend so ein Müll kommt, dann nicht.
So, in der Zwischenzeit gucken wir uns mal kurz an.
Der neue Trailer von dem Spiel der Battlefield, Battlefield, der Ex-Battlefield-Macher.
Embark Studios heißen die jetzt.
Alter, das sieht so Hipster-mäßig aus wie Apex, ich weiß nicht.
Es hat wenig mit Battlefield zu tun auf jeden Fall.
Na, wobei, wobei, ganz ehrlich, es sieht aus wie Battlefield mit Superkräften.
Ja, mehr, mehr Effekt-Overload bitte.
Das ist quasi so Battlefield mit Overwatch.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht Frostbite, es ist glaube ich Unreal Engine.
Aber, und das muss man schon mal dem Game zugute halten,
bevor wir es gespielt haben,
es hat irgendwie so einen gewissen eigenen Charakter und Style.
Auch wenn es ein bisschen Apex-Hipster aussieht,
ist es aber von der Grafik her schon wieder gar nicht mehr.
Das hier könnte jetzt eins zu eins ein Apex-Held sein.
Aber ansonsten, ja, und man sieht Gameplay.
Es ist nicht irgendein komisches Cinematic-Ding, ja.
Also, Cinematic ist es trotzdem, aber wir sehen keins.
So stellen wir es uns mal theoretisch vor.
Also nicht wie Battlefield-Trailer da am Anfang.
Okay, einmal noch Stranded.
Neue Map zum Abschluss.
Das ist gut.
Weiß man, ob das auch für PS5 kommt?
Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass die meisten Games heutzutage für PS5, PC und Xbox kommen.
Oder Konsolen-exklusiv.
PC-exklusiv, gibt's doch.
Fällt euch irgendwas?
PC-exklusiv ist ein der letzten Jahre, so Mainstream-mäßig.
Also ich meine damit jetzt nicht Rust oder sowas.
Wobei selbst Rust ist glaube ich nicht PC-exklusiv, oder?
Kann da mal einer sterben?
Sterben, please.
Stadia-only, ja, Stadia-only.
Die zählt nicht.
Stadia-only ist dead.
Killed by Google.
Valorant, ist Valorant PC-exklusiv?
Oh Leute, ich kann nicht mehr spielen.
Monka!
Ich kann nicht mehr zielen, wirklich.
Es ist vorbei.
Boomer-Hirn, Boomer-Hirn ist überfordert.
Guckt euch an, einfach rausgerannt.
Was, Valorant soll für Mobile kommen?
Wirklich?
Mobile?
Ernsthaft?
Also das letzte, worauf ich mir ein aimlastiges Spiel wie Valorant vorstellen kann, ist ja
mal tatsächlich Mobile.
Oh shit, zu spät.
Natürlich, also wenn du Valorant auf Mobile spielen willst, das braucht ja einen integrierten
Aimbot, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Das ist...
Ich meine, es ist kein CS, aber es ist schon ein äußerst aim- und point-and-click, so
wenn man das mal aufwendig hört, dann ist das schon klar...
Das geht einfach nicht.
Was spart ihr von einemrangigen Spiel?
Das gibt es doch nicht...
Das gibt es doch nicht, ihr wisst doch gar nicht!
Wir spielen ja nur ein Vogel!
Das muss doch gar nichts sein!
Okay, haben wir noch einen Aimbot, oder?
Okay, wo haben wir den?
Ne, wir haben einen Aimbot.
Den haben wir schon.
Und...
Was nochmal?
Was haben wir?
Einen Dachfus.
Einen Dachfus?
Nee, da haben wir doch eigentlich nur einen Aimbot.
Ja, ja, ich würde auch, wenn ich благодарsteine...
Was ist denn das?
Was macht das?
Leute, Max noch mal 10 Minuten konzentrieren, Alter.
Könnt ihr das easy gewinnen, wenn ich ordentlich spiele.
Eats.
Acht Stunden am Stück.
Ist vorbei, Leute.
Kann ich da mal machen.
Alter, das stirbt nicht.
Okay, wenigstens ein bisschen was gemacht.
Wenigstens ein bisschen was gemacht.
Drei gekillt.
Nice, okay.
Wir haben A.
Weiter geht's.
Außenrum, außenrum.
Shit.
Okay, Max, ich hol dich.
Nein, mach ich nicht.
Sag mal, können die umkippen?
Der wird einfach abgesmogt jetzt.
Abgesmogt und pushen.
Fuck, Munition leer.
Für welchen Preis meinst du denn, wird man sich das Game antun?
15 Euro.
15 Euro und dann durchgehend Rush spielen und gut ist.
Easy.
Oh, nee.
Mann.
Wie viele Tickets haben wir noch?
19.
Okay, letzte.
Letzte Attack.
18.
Pass auf, wir faken jetzt.
Six Head.
Die denken jetzt, wir kommen hinten.
Lang machen wir aber gar nicht.
Oh.
Ausgerechnet da ist einer.
Okay, wenn wir jetzt nicht durchkommen, wird das nix.
F, F, F.
Okay, ein paar Sachen gekillt.
Die aimen nicht in den Rauch, die schauen nur, wo sich was bewegt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Fuck.
Na gut.
Boah, jetzt reicht's mir aber, ey.
Alter.
Boah.
Dreieinhalb Stunden ist für mich echt genug.
Das ist das Maximum erreicht.
Es gibt ja Leute, es gibt ja Leute, konnte ich früher auch.
Die haben acht Stunden am Stück durchgespielt und dann so wie die erste Stunde quasi.
Und die sind erst aufgewärmt nach drei Stunden.
Da haben wir noch irgendwas Sinniges unlockt.
Was ist denn das da?
Shotgun?
Returnen wir mal zum Menü.
Gibt auch Leute, die machen das zwanzig und ja, es gibt auch Leute, die machen irgendwelche, ähm, Sub, Sub, Subberton, wie auch immer, Streams für achtundvierzig Stunden.
MonkaS.
Alter, jetzt reicht's, ey.
Dudel anmachen.
Ey, das will ich mir nicht angucken.
So.
Chat.
Gibt's noch irgendwelche spannenden Sachen.
Was ist denn so passiert die letzten paar Tage?
Google hat Stadia dicht gemacht.
Ähm.
Chrome wirft Adblocker raus.
Wobei das sich ja wahrscheinlich schon wieder erstmal gelegt hat für ein weiteres Jahr.
Was hältst du von den Twitch-Veränderungen?
Was gab's denn da die letzte Woche?
Oder meinst du allgemein so die letzten paar Jahre über?
Gab es die letzte Woche irgendwelche großen Twitch-Veränderungen?
Äh.
Ach so, 50-50 für alle, ist mir egal.
Ach ja, Glücksspielverbot.
Ja gut, jetzt wird FIFA Pack Opening gemacht, anstatt Slot Machine Stream.
Bezos kann sich's nicht leisten.
Ja, das haben wir zusammen gesehen und ich bin immer noch der Meinung, ich kauf mir wahrscheinlich ne 40-90.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich bin, der Preis ist krass.
Das ist, das ist es.
Es doppelte.
Von der 1080 Ti damals.
Wobei, die hab ich ja nicht mal bezahlt, aber trotzdem.
Oh, Twitch-Werbung ist richtig.
Tatsächlich, das ist was, was mich wirklich nervt.
Twitch-Werbung ist total übertrieben seit ein paar Wochen.
Laufen ist irgendwo Werbung.
Die Gambling-Streamer sind süchtig bestimmt, ein Großteil, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ein Großteil, aber auf der anderen Seite, für die ist es halt insofern geil.
Die können quasi gesponsort süchtig sein.
Das würden viele am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof auch gerne sein.
Da kann er Free-, da kann's Free-, oh, Free-TV.
Ganz ehrlich, ich guck so gut wie kein Fern-, so gut wie kein Fernseher mehr.
Das einzige, was ich öffentlich-rechtlich konsumiere ab und zu, ist auf YouTube so...
Ich, so, so irgendwie...
Handwerksvideos oder so, wo irgendwie einer, heute bauen wir einen Swimmingpool oder so, oder heute bauen wir eine Bank oder einen Tisch oder sowas.
Das guck ich mir manchmal an, das ist immer...
Äußerst beruhigend, das, das kann ich mir einmal angucken zum Einschlafen.
Nein, äh, nee, nee, nee, 70-30, 70-30 ist das, was früher die ganzen großen, also viele große Streamer gekriegt haben, 70 für den Streamer.
Und 30 für Twitch und bei allen anderen ist es 50-50.
Das Traumschiff, nee, das guck ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass das mit Florian Silbereisen ist.
Falls es das noch ist.
Baust du...
Ich baue meine PCs immer zusammen.
Serious Max?
Dankeschön, 26 Monate.
Massive Subscription.
Pog.
Lohnt sich das?
Also bisher hatten wir immer 50-50.
Nee, der hat ein neues?
Nee, das gucken wir uns aber morgen früh an, nicht jetzt.
4080 mit 12 und mit 16, weil die 4080 mit 12 GB quasi eine ganz andere Grafikkarte ist.
Das ist nicht nur der RAM, der Unterschied ist.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall die mit 16G.
Cool oder Casino Streams?
Keines von beiden.
In letzter Zeit gucke ich gerne Dota-Streams.
Ist zwar weder Pool noch Casino, auch wenn ich es nicht selbst spiele.
Ha!
Naja, die neuen Nvidia Grafikkarten gibt es wahrscheinlich für UVP.
Nur, dass der UVP total abfuck hoch ist.
Fragt mich, was alle jetzt mit ihrem Chromecast machen, die Stadia, die damit Stadia, die es für Stadia gekauft haben.
Gab ja so einen Chromecast Pro am Anfang für Stadia.
Ich bin froh, dass ich den Kram abbestellt habe.
Ich hatte das damals bestellt, weil ich mir gedacht habe, einfach mal gucken.
Ich, ich, wie gesagt, ich habe nie wirklich an Stadia geglaubt.
Aber ich habe ja bei einmal gucken und dann haben sie es irgendwie trotz Vorbestellung verschoben.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, wisst ihr was, ihr könnt mich mal weg.
Wenn komplett refundet, wahrscheinlich kriegt man für einen Stadia Controller in 20 Jahren 3000 Euro bei irgendeiner Ebay-Aktion.
Für irgendwelche Sammlungen.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, wer will so einen Fail wie Stadia haben?
Bei einem Super Nintendo vielleicht, aber nicht.
Eher nicht bei einem Stadia Controller.
Hat der ein neues Video?
Alpha, Alpha 4 Games.
Halo Infinite, peinlicher Battle Royale Versuch.
Das habe ich mir erst gar nicht gegeben.
Ich habe ja eine Weile recht viel Halo Infinite gespielt, aber was mich bei Halo Infinite übelst abgefuckt hat, war die Geschichte mit.
Dass der.
Controller-Support so übertrieben war versus PC.
Das ist nicht so dieses, das ist nicht im Rahmen von einem Call of Duty Aim Assist, wo das auch schon teilweise fragwürdig ist.
Gerade wenn es am Model kleben bleibt.
Aber in Halo ist ja wirklich so, das stickt richtig dran.
Und du siehst das.
Also es ist so, eines der Standard-Duelle in Halo.
Mit, mit.
Pass mal auf, ich male jetzt mal meinen Master-Chief hier.
Das ist der Master-Chief, so.
Und wenn man auf den Master-Chief schießt in Halo.
Dann läuft, der läuft hin und her.
Also, so die Standard-DMR-Dinge, One-on-One ist.
Man läuft voreinander links und rechts hin und her und versucht sich auf den Kopf zu schießen, so.
Und mit dem Controller musst du einmal hier irgendwie ungefähr auf diese Region gehen.
Und kannst hin und her laufen.
Und es bleibt mehr oder weniger konstant auf dem Kopf.
Mit dem PC, mit der Maus, musst du wirklich den Kopf, die Bewegung tracken.
Und auch alles ausgleichen.
Weil vielleicht macht der nicht so, sondern macht mal so.
Oder, oder, oder so, oder so, ja.
Das musst du alles ausgleichen.
Mit dem Controller ist es einfach nur sticky.
Also das war riesen, also, man muss sich mal überlegen.
Wenn, wenn die Top-Ladder-Spieler fast alle Controller spielen, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Ja wirklich gut.
Waren die danach ja auch nicht mehr.
Also ich finde, ODST für die Singleplayer-Kampagne war okay.
Auch wenn der Soundtrack irgendwie, weiß nicht, warum der Preis gekrönt war, ich fand nicht so gut.
Ähm, Reach war auch schon so, pff, ah ja.
Und alles danach, kannst du klicken, äh, bezieht sich jetzt auf was?
PC?
Also wie gesagt, ich will meinen, ich, ich wollte mir einen neuen PC kaufen.
Und ich hab, hier, guck mal, komm, komm, komm, hier, ich hab, ich hab ausgerechnet im Stream letztens, ich brauch ungefähr, tja.
Skript Internet TXT.
Ah, nein, das ist was anderes.
Das ist irgendein, irgendein Videoskript.
Für was war denn das?
Die meisten Leuten verzichten aufs Denken.
Ja, das ist korrekt, die meisten Leute verzichten aufs Denken.
Pff, da hatte ich wohl recht, was ich geschrieben hab.
Aber, ich such jetzt eigentlich das PC, meine PC-Zusammenstellung, aber finde ich nicht mehr.
Also, die würde 4500 Euro ungefähr kosten, was halt wirklich ziemlich hart ist.
Skript Internet.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich hier irgendwelche Videoskripts hab.
Das war auch eher so ein, so ein, ich, ich hab mal irgendwie was aufgeschrieben und weiß nicht, ob ich da draußen ein Video mache.
Das war nix, was ich mal aufgenommen hab, glaub ich.
Oder?
Egal.
Vielleicht war es das letzte Internet-Ausbau-Video.
Ja, ich hab auch ein 8000, ich hab ein 8700K und ein 1080Ti.
Nö, noch nix, das liegt auf dem Sofa, lul.
Es ist schon teuer, ja.
Ich brauch eigentlich noch gar keinen neuen Rechner.
Ist halt das Ding.
Ich, ich würd den neuen Rechner quasi nur kaufen, weil ich endlich mal wieder einen neuen Rechner haben will, was eigentlich total hängen geblieben ist.
Zumal ich eh nur 1080p spiele.
Also kein Ding.
Na gut, wem dem auch sei, Chat.
Ich geh jetzt auf.
Reicht.
Raid, wen könnte man raiden?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin jetzt zu Boomer für überlegen.
Der Friseur, den würd ich sofort raiden.
Al Friese.
Wenn er online wäre.
Mal da.
Das wär cool, wenn der mal wieder online gehen würde.
Aber, kannste ja knicken.
Irgendwelche Weep-Games.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn, CU.